Who Remain separated years after the
Trump Administration took children from
their parents at the border a policy
that will be a permanent stain on our
country's conscience certainly more
remains to be done
I believe the solution to our
long-standing border challenges is for
Congress to finally fix our broken
immigration system and explain legal
pathway expand legal Pathways of
migration for vetted individuals who
want to contribute to our society
doing so will allow border Personnel to
focus on real threats to the homeland
security but human Smuggler put human
Smugglers out of business and help
ensure migrants are treated with dignity
goals everyone should agree on
but a question remains do we want to
finally overcome our border challenges
or do we want to use this issue for
partisan attacks I guess we'll see in
today's hearing I thank the chairman and
look forward to our discussion today and
I yield back
thank you uh ranking member other
members of the committee are reminded
that opening statements may be submitted
for the record
I'm pleased to have a distinguished
panel of witnesses before us today on
this very important topic ask that our
Witnesses please rise and raise their
right hand
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you will give before this committee
today the committee on homeland security
of the United States House of
Representatives will be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth so
help you God
thank you you may be seated let the
record reflect that the witnesses have
answered in the affirmative thank you
I'd like I'd now like to formally
introduce our witnesses to everyone
today Miss Rebecca kiesling is a family
law attorney from Michigan who
tragically lost her two sons Kyler and
Caleb to fentanyl poisoning we extend
our condolences and thank her for being
here The Honorable Mark Lamb is Sheriff
of penile County Arizona Sheriff lamb
oversees a county the size of
Connecticut and has worked diligently to
keep its population safe from the many
effects of the Border crisis
Mr Robert trenchel's president and CEO
of the Yuma Regional Medical Center in
Yuma Arizona Dr trenchel brings nearly
20 years of health care experience and
medical management experience and
currently oversees the hospitals the
hospital overflow created by the flow of
illegal migration
Dr David Byer am I pronouncing your name
correctly beer like the beverage
cool uh Dr beer is or Mr Beer is the
associate director of immigration
studies at Cato Institute focusing on
border security and immigration
I thank all the witnesses for being here
today and I now recognize Miss kiesling
for five minutes to summarize her
opening statement
chairman Greene ranking member
pardon me
chairman Greene ranking member Thompson
and distinguished members of the
committee I'm Rebecca kiesling I'm a
mother I I'm the mother to Caleb and
Kyler as well as three teenage daughters
our family's been through a lot
I lost my two sons
um Caleb was age 20 and Kyler was age 18
on July 29th of 2020.
um it was absolutely A Perfect Storm
there were there was also a 17 year old
girl
Sophia Harris who died along with them
and the drug dealer Lorenzo Brabo was
spared by Narcan
and he ended up getting 8 to 15 years
for killing three people
because to the law enforcement this was
a breakthrough case
my former law partner her husband is a
Sheriff Deputy he's a detective in the
next town over he tells me he's got a
stack
every day there's a stack of dead people
and there's no leads but in our case
there was a lead the drug dealer was
there and he was another addict and so
because he survived they had leads to
who he got it from and they actually
could try to start tracing it back and
the
law enforcement made it clear to me that
this fentanyl came from Mexico it came
from our Southern border
I didn't know what fentanyl was
I didn't know what Narcan was I had
heard of the opioid epidemic I thought
you know people are getting prescription
drugs and getting addicted and then
getting in on the streets and that it
affects their ability to work I didn't
know that people were dying
um I didn't know that my boys were
taking anything that could kill them
they didn't think that they were either
they thought that they were safe with
pills and I'm going to read some
statements from my sons that they wrote
shortly before their deaths and you'll
see that that's exactly the case
but the government knew
the government's known for years and
years
um the Year my son Caleb was born 2020
there were roughly 20 000 drug related
deaths in the United States the year
they died I'm sorry it was 2000 it was
the year he was born
and the year that they died 2020 there
were over a hundred thousand
for 2021 almost 110 000.
um the CDC I saw yesterday says that
fentanyl deaths Rose 22 percent from
2020 to 2021.
I mean it's unbelievable you would think
that one death
from fentanyl come across our Southern
border would be enough to sound the
alarm
and my kid's story was high profile
because three young people died
there was another child from our
hometown who died the same day it wasn't
in the news you don't hear about it
because it was just one death
so it wasn't like extraordinary
I found out from the
um funeral home that they have tons of
these cases
regularly
I'm from Rochester Hills Michigan we
were you know in Money Magazine right
ranked in top 10 cities live in America
a few years ago
um our school is
is top five in Michigan
but they this all started at the schools
and the law enforcement aren't doing all
they can but they usually don't have
liens you have to stop it from its
source
now
if we had Chinese troops lining up along
our Southern border
with weapons aimed at our people with
weapons of mass destruction aimed at our
cities you damn well know you would do
something about it
we have a weather balloon
from China going across our country
nobody died and everybody's freaking out
about it
but a hundred thousand die every year
and nothing's being done not enough is
being done numbers are going up not down
and you talk about children being taken
away from their parents
my children were taken away from me
a hundred thousand Americans every year
are having their children 200 000
because it's both parents right
are having their children taken away
from them
this should not be politicized it's not
about race fennel doesn't care about
race
see you talk about welcoming those
Crossing or border seeking protection
you're welcoming drug dealers across our
border
you're giving them protection you're not
protecting our children
I'm in support groups on Facebook
with their thousands of parents who have
lost their children every day faces are
added it's dehumanizing it's
demoralizing
there's parents who are
um they paint the chairs purple
and they kind of make shrines for their
children
and I see those purple chairs because
purple is the
um you know color for a drug death and I
don't use the term drug overdose because
this was not an overdose this was murder
my children got fake Percocets
that were fentanyl there was no Percocet
in it at all
and it's a homicide
not overdose
but they have these purple chairs and I
saw that and I thought I don't ever want
to have purple chairs I don't need a
reminder I don't want to remember my
son's frail they died I want to remember
them for how they lived but I'm here
justifying today
because there are other people who need
to remember
I don't need a purple chair in my house
Congress needs a purple chair
the White House needs a purple chair to
never forget about all those who are
being slaughtered
this is a war
act like it do something
my son
Kyler shortly before he died this is
what he wrote and I want to share the
writing so they can have a chance to
testify
he wrote his goals number one stay away
from drugs and alcohol it's not worth it
to surround myself with good influence
people three stay away from nicotine
four treat people with more respect
don't burn Bridges if I find another
method to cope that works for me six get
closer with Jaden
seven start doing something physical to
get in shape eat start working a lot to
stay focused nine finish school and he
did
the day before he died he graduated ten
have a better relationship with my
parents eleven do anything and
everything to better myself and my
health twelve listen when told to do
something 13 don't f up probo or I'll
have a felony on my record 14 report to
any and every drug test 15 don't follow
my birth mom steps
16 be there for my brother my only Blood
Brother 17 I can do anything that I put
my mind and effort to
okay I'd like to have the photos of my
sons shown
foreign
we also found Caleb's testimony he wrote
out weeks earlier because he wanted to
start speaking in schools and to tell
other kids why not to do drugs why not
to ever try it
he said my name is Caleb kiesling I'm 20
years old
I've dabbled in drugs I've never touched
crack meth or heroin as I've grown up
watching my birth mother ruin her life
and watch all her friends pass away from
heroin overdoses and I've also growing
up hearing how destructive those three
substances are so I've stayed away from
them and do not see myself ever trying
them again he thought he was safe
he didn't want to die
he says um I was an athlete I played
soccer from a young age all the way up
until my junior year I got A's in school
with student council president and end
up graduating early and I've held a
full-time job since I was 16 years old
I'm extremely intelligent I have my
parents to thank for that as they stress
to keep my nose in a book teaching me
that knowledge is true power and is the
only thing nobody could ever take from
you
before I got caught I had already
realized that my life needed to change
I'd been in the process of signing out
with the Navy I scored in the 90th
percentile on the PCAT test I have too
many routes available to me not to
succeed so even if the military isn't my
path I'm gonna have a good future I can
feel that in my bones
I'm built to succeed and my issues have
only made me stronger my shortcomings
don't even begin to Define who I am and
don't even begin to speak to what I've
been through and overcame
I can only claim just a little credit
for it because it's by the Lord's Grace
and protection that I'm alive and here
to tell my story he has watched over my
whole life even when I refuse to accept
his presence and existence Rebecca
we're gonna
we're gonna need to move move to our
next witness okay I know you're
I'm at I can't imagine none of us here
can imagine I'm so sorry but we'll there
will be questions and and you'll get to
share more in a moment okay
thank you
sure flam I now recognize you for your
testimony thank you you have five
minutes chairman green is team members
thank you I'm going to go through this
quick I hope I don't sound like a
Livestock Auctioneer here my heart goes
out to Rebecca and so many other
families
um I am the sheriff of Pinal County
Arizona my county is located between
Phoenix and Tucson it is approximately
the size of the state of Connecticut we
are not a border County however we are
52 miles uh from the border at our
closest point through the desert uh we
have an Indian reservation on the south
end which actually runs into Mexico and
the cartel for decades has pushed people
through and it hasn't changed recently
we are also 71 miles off the border on
the I-10 Interstate this is important
because the ice 10 interstate is one of
the main arteries for a human and drug
trafficking into America the drugs that
make it into your States come through my
County at one point we are let me give
you some of our statistics just to show
you how much this affects us we have had
a 377 percent increase in the last two
years with TR for traffic stops
involving human smuggling and
trafficking we have had a 461 percent
increase in Pursuits involving human
smuggling putting my citizens at risk
now the drivers are predominantly
American but oftentimes they are
juveniles being actively recruited by
the cartels on social media paying them
thousand dollars per person that they
transport into my community a lot of
what we see are not layups you hear the
term layups layups are people that come
through the Border turn themselves into
border patrol and claim Asylum what I
deal with in the Tucson sector in my
county is we deal with the the godaways
those people you hear about the godaways
that's in our County
these are people that are going to be
dressed in camouflage clothes
carpet shoes
and backpacks like this they're littered
throughout my desert I just picked these
up uh Sunday morning and this is what I
see all every day this is the sign of
somebody who's trying to come in
undetected and illegally into this
country
the problem is is that we are allowing
the weak policies that we have in place
here on a national level and the lack of
fortitude to secure our border has
created an opportunity for the cartels
not only do we deal with the criminal
element we deal with the humanitarian
element every summer we spend our
helicopter our resources it's a drain on
my resources my canines are dedicated uh
solely to interdiction I have an
anti-smuggling unit my helicopter we had
10 events yesterday alone one of them
was a 9-1-1 call we had a gentleman we
had to go find that the cartel left for
dead a year or so ago when we found him
he was laying under a Palo Verde tree we
had to give them three bags of IV to
bring them back and while we were doing
that there were seven more 9-1-1 calls
on the board for lost injured or left
behind Smugglers
the people are being tricked and trapped
into coming here by these cartels
because of our policies or lack of
when they come here the women are being
raped we had a woman we caught a while
back that had a baggie full of pills and
we said what are these pills and she
says well and I came across the border I
knew I'd be raped multiple times these
are morning after pills
and we lost our moral compass so bad
that we put politics in front of people
they're raping the women using the
raping the children using them as pawns
often time putting them in the sex trade
here in America slavery is as prolific
it's super prolific nowadays they're
extorting the men
the cartel knows this how many times can
they sell you a pill
once how many times can they sell you a
woman
hundreds how many times can they sell
you a child hundreds and this is what
the cartel is doing I don't want to
dwell on that but I want to get onto the
drugs in our County we have seen a 600
percent increase in fentanyl in my
community in 2018 we had zero m30
fentanyl pill seizures in 2019 we had
around 700 pills in 2020 we had over 200
000 pills in 2021 we had over 1.2
million bills and this last year we had
over 1.4 million pills come into my
community I hope that one of you will
ask me about xylazine which is something
we're now finding in our communities I
want to get on to the children because I
think this is important because this is
what deals with Rebecca and so many
other families in the state of Arizona
in 2021 we lost 44 children to
poisonings under the age of 17. seven
were under the age of one year old
if that doesn't mobilize the forces of
this country to stop this problem I
don't know what will
this is what we deal with on a daily
basis and I hear that ninety percent
come through the ports those numbers are
not what we're seeing it's 50 50. 52.48
and the fact that you think they think
they can bring it through our borders is
not something to brag about that we
catch it because what that tells me is
the cartel is so confident that they're
going to get those those drugs through
your borders they come right through our
front door
we have said with the amount of seizures
we've had have saved probably this
entire country multiple times over
this is something we need to address I
know I'm over time I just want to say
thank you to the partners that we have
with border patrol ice I thank you for
the stone garden funds which allow us to
help you in your mission we've got a
tremendous amount of work to do I will
tell you the lines of communication were
severed as when this Administration took
over we have zero communication with the
federal side which is disappointing
something we lost when this
Administration came in I would also just
like to say in closing that we've got to
do better on
saying that the the messaging the media
the politicians you've got to stop
saying this is a manufactured crisis the
the statistics I've given you say
otherwise and you have to stop saying
that the border is secure because the
border is not secure and with that I
will uh turn it back over to the to the
chairman and I thank you and I
appreciate the opportunity to be here
and look forward to answering questions
thank you Sheriff William I now
recognize Mr trenchel for five minutes
to summarize his opening statement good
morning chairman Greene and members of
the homeland security committee thank
you for inviting me here today to give
you a first-hand account of the impact
that open borders have had on our
hospital and community over the past
year and more Yuma Regional Medical
Center is a 406 bed hospital that offers
a full range of acute care services the
closest hospitals that do what we do are
located 180 miles away in Phoenix or San
Diego given our geographic location our
hospital and health system holds a deep
responsibility of keeping local families
close to home for care whenever possible
for many who live here traveling out of
town for care is simply an unbearable
challenge they depend on us to be here
our mission to meet the needs of our
community is always at the Forefront of
every decision I also want to
acknowledge the work and heart of our
staff at Yuma Regional Medical Center
who continue to care for patients each
and every day they provide the same high
level of care for every patient we do
not treat anyone differently and we take
pride in that if your mother or
grandchild walks through our doors or if
a migrant walks through our doors they
would receive this receive the same
level of care
over the last approximately year and a
half we've had a highly significant
number of migrants cross the border into
our community our Hospital saw an
increase in the number of migrants
seeking care beginning in the late fall
early winter of 2021 they arrived to our
hospital room in a multitude of ways
some patients come to us via border
patrol who typically release them from
custody upon arrival other patients walk
in take taxis some even come by Uber as
I've said we are the only acute care
hospital in the area which means
diversion to another facility is not an
option we are it some migrants come to
us with minor ailments but many of them
come in with significant disease we've
had migrant patients on dialysis cardiac
catheterization and in need of heart
surgery many are very sick they have
long-term complications of chronic
disease that have not been cared for
some end up in the ICU for 60 days or
more one of the largest cohorts we have
seen are maternity patients who present
with little or no prenatal care these
higher risk pregnancies and births
result in higher complication rates and
longer hospital stays due to a lack of
prenatal care many of these baby these
require a stay in our neonatal Intensive
Care Unit some for a month or more at a
time there are Language and Cultural
concerns with migrant patients and we
work through those but when you consider
the volume in Associated case management
that come with it resources have to
support this as well migrants often
require three times the amount of Human
Resources to resolve their cases and
provide them a safe discharge as defined
by CMS that effort includes assistance
with locating families making sure they
have a safe place to go when they are
discharged arranging and sometimes
purchasing durable medical equipment
when needed we have paid for emergency
Air transport when they need a higher
level of care we pay for hotel rooms
taxis and car seats we do these things
because it's the right thing to do from
a humanitarian perspective but it also
allows us to open open a hospital bed
sooner for another patient in our
community none of these expenses are
included in the 26 million dollar figure
our reality is this we have delivered
over 26 million dollars in uncompensated
care to these individuals in the
12-month period of time from December 21
to November of 2022 that's an auditable
figure let me me assure you it is not an
approximation that number comes from a
detailed review of unpaid patient bills
directly attributed to migrant patients
26 million dollars in uncompensated care
is is simply an unsustainable business
model while this is a huge number that
we have validated the point is that any
number is not acceptable it is an
unsustainable model to have a hospital
like ours via the entire burden of
paying for migrant Health Care no
business or service can survive ongoing
large-scale expense without any
offsetting Revenue because of this surge
of Migrant care we've had to hire
additional staff at a time when
Healthcare labor post pandemic is higher
than ever every dollar in uncompensated
care has a direct impact on our Hospital
migrant patients are receiving free care
they have no ability to pay we have no
ability to Bill anyone we don't know
their final destination we don't know
anything about them let me put this into
perspective 26 million dollars is equal
to the benefits to support benefits and
salaries to support 212 bedside nurses
the city of Yuma has a hundred thousand
people we've had three hundred thousand
people across the border in Yuma in one
year that's three times the population
of Yuma coming across the border we are
the only hospital within a three-hour
radius which means they come to us we've
contacted our state and federal leaders
no one has a solution they're willing to
listen and are empathetic but so far we
have no Solutions or any reimbursement
for the care
we've been at this for well over a year
now on behalf of our entire hospital
care team I'm here seeking your
leadership and support to find a payer
source for the care we have already
provided and will continue to provide in
the future and to put long-term
Solutions into action that will support
Our Daily Commitment to be here for our
community for years to come one Hospital
should not and Canna bear the health
care costs of a national migrant problem
that is deeply impacting Arizona and our
community we need a revenue source for
this patient population so we can
sustainably provide high quality care to
all comers and remain viable for the
future thank you
thank you Mr trentrell I now recognize
Mr Beer for five minutes to summarize
his opening statement
chairman Greene ranking member Thompson
and distinguished members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify for more than four decades
the Cato Institute has produced original
research on immigration showing a Freer
more orderly and more lawful immigration
system creates a Freer wealthier and
safer country
we see people as the ultimate resource
the given the freedom to thrive people
regardless of birthplace are a benefit
to our society
unfortunately the U.S immigration system
is so narrow and so backlogged that most
people who want to come to this country
have no legal way to do so they have no
line
as a result the U.S ranks in the bottom
third of wealthy countries for its
immigrant share of the population
this restrictive system is harming our
communities from the largest cities to
the smallest towns
the worker shortage averaging nearly 10
million open jobs
per month
has cost the U.S nearly one trillion
dollars in Lost productivity in the last
year alone
population decline is eroding tax bases
in cities both large and small nearly
three quarters of America's counties had
more deaths than births in the last year
and U.S population growth is the lowest
it has ever been in our entire history
this restrictive system also causes
illegal immigration which can tear apart
communities when employees employers and
spouses of U.S citizens are deported
immigrants are not undermining the
safety of U.S communities just the
opposite Census Bureau data show that
legal and illegal immigrants are half as
likely to end up behind bars as U.S born
residents during the 1990s when the
Immigrant population grew faster than it
had at any point in over a century crime
fell rapidly it fell faster and further
in immigrant dense communities
about 350 000 immigrants serve in
protective occupations as police
officers detectives and private security
immigrants work with police to solve
crimes
about
000 immigrants right now are awaiting
status based on their cooperation with
local investigations
and there are countless examples of U.S
communities turned around by the
economic revitalization brought by
immigrants
immigrants increase state and local tax
revenues by over 250 billion dollars per
year more resources to keep communities
safe
the committee is right to investigate
the scourge of fentanyl deaths
but immigrants are not the cause
fentanyl is overwhelmingly smuggled
through ports of Entry largely by U.S
citizens U.S citizens accounted for 86
percent of convicted fentanyl
traffickers in 2021.
despite arresting over 700 000 illegal
entrants so far this year less than one
percent of cbp's fentanyl seizures have
come from people carrying it across the
border illegally
the restrictions on trade and travel
that started in 2020 have only
exacerbated the problem because fentanyl
is 50 times more potent than heroin it
can supply the same Market with far
fewer trips
so with fewer trips and more scrutiny in
2020 and 2021 traffickers switched from
heroin
to Fentanyl and Fentanyl deaths doubled
border policies have failed victims by
making drugs more potent and deadly
Congress should focus on helping drug
users not Banning immigrants
the Crackdown on Asylum under title 42
has also failed to secure the Border
now that requesting Asylum is no longer
an option evasion of border patrol has
increased five-fold
from 2019 to 2023 forcing immigrants to
cross in more remote more rural areas of
the Border has led to more suffering and
death which is straining rural hospitals
we have seen repeatedly that closing off
legal options
to immigrate creates illegal immigration
while opening them up reduces it
the administration's new parole
sponsorship programs for Cubans Haitians
Venezuelans and nicaraguans are already
working to reduce illegal Migration by
those populations by over 90 percent
these programs Empower ordinary
Americans in every Community to help fix
the Border
Congress should work with them
thank you
thank you Mr Beer members are Rec will
be recognized by order
of seniority for their five minutes of
questioning an additional round of
questioning may be called for after all
members have been recognized I now
recognize myself for five minutes of
questions
before I start I I just want to share a
few things because it's been talked
about this being a decades-long problem
it has been there's no doubt there have
been there's been a problem but uh in
the entire previous administration's
four years 2.4 million Encounters in in
just two years we've had 4.7 million
encounters
1.2 million gotaways
uh I can do that math 5.9 million people
25 states in the United States have
populations less than 4.6 million let
that number sink in
and the the removal of the policies
at the on day one the executive orders
that were written and reversing policies
implemented that solved many of this or
you know really
began to solve this problem we're done
away with
and a surge of people came to our border
and the drug cartels have taken
advantage of the situation
by the neutralizing effects that I
talked about in my opening statement
it was also mentioned earlier about the
humanitarian
problems from previous Administrations
I remember sitting in this committee
right over there
when I was a freshman
and there was this big to do about two
migrant deaths
we weren't in charge at that time
but it was a big hullabaloo because
there were two migrant deaths any death
we should make a big deal out of it
in the past two years under this
administration's policies under Marcus's
Reckless Behavior Reckless uh you know
border policies 1400.
migrants have died
here's one just floating floating in the
river
fourteen hundred we talked about it was
a humanitarian crisis in the previous
administration
nothing now
1400 over 1400.
yes
this is my arcus's failure
um
Mr lamb or Sheriff lamb I'd like to
start with you today Mr Beer was
mentioning some statistics about who's
carrying the drugs into the country
um
those carpet shoes you showed earlier do
you think those are counted in his
statistics
the video that I showed earlier of all
this just parade of people carrying
drugs into our country are they counted
in his statistics
uh Mr chairman no sir and I find it
comical that a lot of researchers and
politicians that like to tell us what's
going on on the border but they don't
ever come down to the border to actually
see it in person we're telling you
statistics that we see every day here's
the remnants of it this tells you
everything you need to know and I've got
thousands of these in hundreds of spots
throughout my county and those aren't in
the statistics and they're certainly not
coming through the ports of Entry are
they Sheriff lamb I know they are not
coming through the ports of Industry
thank you
um
Rebecca I
I really appreciate you being here
and I know the difficulty of you being
here
um one of our fellow Witnesses today
Sheriff lamb
um
mentioned and talked about the flow of
Fentanyl
he's 55 miles from the border you're in
Michigan I think right uh quite a ways
from the border do you mind elaborating
a little bit on how it's impacted your
community and
I mean you shared your story but but
you're with other
parents who've lost their children can
you share the story of how it's
impacting your community
well I'll tell you in the support groups
you know there's
there have been some parents who have
committed suicide
um siblings who have
um it's devastating families it's been
very difficult for my daughters
um one daughter she went off to Michigan
State and came home after semester
um
it was just too painful uh now she she
is attending in our hometown at Oakland
University
um
one of my son's friends was
waiting tables at the same restaurant
where my daughter was and I I went to
eat there last summer and he came up to
me and he said that
he had been friends with both of my sons
but really good friends with Kyler and I
remember they had worked together
um for a while and he told me that he
got clean from drugs after my son's
deaths and he said
um he completely stopped doing marijuana
in fact like he went he stopped doing
any kind of drugs he said I want you to
know that your son's death started a
movement in our hometown
and he said so that when people show up
with pills
um they're ostracized and they're you
know
um they're condemned you know but he
said but I think you know for how long
how many of the kids in the high schools
now know about my son's deaths
thank you very much Mr chairman and uh
Miss kiesling I'm sure I expressed the
sentiment of every member uh on this
committee about your tragic loss uh I'm
a grandfather and uh
it would be difficult for any loss
for for a child or a grandchild
so uh Mr Beer uh
there's a
comment that our immigration system
has been broken for many years uh if
what we are seeing at the border now
consequence of that broken system and if
it is can you kind of share your
thoughts on it
absolutely it's a consequence of our
broken legal immigration system if
people have a legal opportunity to come
to this country then they do not choose
the illegal option and so what we're
seeing at the border is a direct
consequence of the decades-long
restrictions on legal immigration and
legal Pathways to come to this country
we have for example no year-round
temporary work visa for people to come
do year-round work in lower skilled
Industries and that is what is driving
all of this ultimately what funds
Smuggler fees and payments what brings
people to the Border whether they're
seeking Asylum or not ultimately the
financing comes from jobs in the United
States where there's economic demand for
people and if we had a legal way to fill
those jobs we would not see the crisis
that we're seeing at our Southern border
and so we have countless examples of
instances in which we have stopped
illegal immigration by opening up legal
channels we did so in the 1950s with the
Bracero guest worker program which
despite its flaws reduced the amount of
illegal immigration by over 90 percent
and kept it very low it was done away
with and what replaced it was decades of
illegal immigration to U.S Farms
uh thank you march uh you know as I said
in my opening statement fixing our
broken immigration system will not only
help migrants fleeing persecution and
poverty but it'll also help us manage
our border human smuggling put them out
of business free law enforcement to
focus on drug smugglers and strengthen
our economy I represent a predominantly
agricultural District in Mississippi uh
the migrant labor force is a key to that
economy staying healthy uh if we can't
create a system that allow those
individuals uh to come whether it's Jan
and cotton whether it's picking uh
harvesting sweet potatoes or whatever
it's a challenge for our Farmers so
somewhere we need to put a system in
place uh to make that happen and I look
forward uh to working with this
committee on trying to get that
comprehensive immigration reform system
put together
uh can you explain how more legal
Pathways to this country would be
helpful not just to migrants but to
America
oh absolutely first of all we're dealing
with this uh significant inflation
crisis in this country and the lost
productivity that I talked about the one
trillion dollars in Lost productivity
from unfilled open jobs in this country
over the last year would go a long way
to reduce prices of goods and services
across the economy when employers can't
fill positions that is lost productivity
that comes right out of consumers
pockets and so the most important
economic phenomenon is the fact that we
are turning away economic growth by
turning away immigrants and if we want
to fill these positions if we want to
expand growth if we want to bring down
inflation one of the best ways to do so
would be to have a legal immigration
process for people to enter the country
lawfully and of course at our borders we
are seeing serious problems there's no
question there are issues at the border
as a result of illegal immigration but
with illegal immigration platform for
people to apply and cross legally those
problems would be greatly dissipated we
talked about car chases that are
injuring Americans we're talking about
recruitment of teenagers to take part in
smuggling activities of of persons those
problems would also dissipate under a
legal immigration system that actually
worked and served the needs of American
communities
okay well uh if we go another round I
might have another question I yield back
the gentleman yields back I now
recognize uh
chairman Higgins from Louisiana for five
minutes questioning thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman is nauseating to
listen to some of this
it's really stunning
I don't know where they find these
people
that don't get it
like breed these people in laboratory
experiments or something
disconnected from reality
it was just a couple of years ago we had
to border under control
and whine on about broken immigration
systems what what western Nation who
Canada France Germany Great Britain
Mexico
all of them have much more restrictive
immigration programs and laws than the
United States of America we're the most
generous
compassionate wealthy Western nation in
the world for immigration
we want citizens of every land to come
to this country legally
our border is wide open and out of
control and Americans are dying because
of it and I know secretary mayorkus is
watching this or having his team of
attorneys watch this good
because over the course of the next year
this committee is going to lay out the
case against you sir
if I could arrest you for violations of
Louisiana revised statutes I would
Louisiana revised Statute 1432 negligent
homicide Louisiana revised Statute 1424
principled to any criminal action
I charge you with thousands of murders
as principled too
18 U.S code 1001 you certainly knowingly
and willfully lied to this body again
and again and again about our border
section 242 Title 18 on the color of the
law
you've deprived Americans of their very
life
including this young lady
the picture behind me
that's Sammy
she's just a little girl
dead from Fentanyl
it came under
your watch
secretary mayor orcas remember her name
I'm going to see to it
that you have plenty of time
in the course of your remaining life to
remember the names the two hundred
thousand Americans who are dead because
of fentanyl coming across a border that
you have blown wide open
Sheriff lamb thank you for being here
sir
I'm sure you understand my passion
having to listen to this nonsense
we could fix our border in one week am I
right Sheriff if we had if we had policy
coming out of the White House that allow
you to enforce the law and empower the
federal agents on our border that a task
was securing the sovereignty of our
nation against the criminal cartels that
control 100 percent of the Mexican side
of our Southern border could we do it
Sheriff lamb had we done it before as
recently as 2019
yes Mr Higgins we could do that maybe a
week might be tight but 30 to 60 days we
could definitely fix this we're America
we can stop this when we decide we want
to stop it when we when we make a
decision to enforce existing law
we can flip this thing around Sheriff
lamb and my remain in a minute
it's a very disturbing development that
we've been we've been watching over the
course of the last year or so these guys
crossing the border are increasingly
violent
and your your man your deputies are
encountering that will you characterize
the demeanor and purpose of a typical
God away that you encounter in your town
and expound upon the
and increase violence that you're
witnessing from these these men yeah
thank you Mr Higgins absolutely we are
seeing increased violence more and more
the ranchers along the border very fear
for their lives every day uh these are
military-aged men that are avoiding
detection at all costs many have paid
between six thousand and twelve thousand
dollars to come here and they don't
that's a lot of money to them and
they're not going back and they're not
going to go down without a fight yeah
we've had traffic stops where they've
tried to run my deputies off the road
while we're trying to stop a load
vehicle a secondary vehicle we'll try to
run them off the road we had one such
vehicle we chased all the way back to
Phoenix to find it was a female with a
one and a half year old child and a
five-month-old child in her car with her
violence is not enough is is absolutely
an option for these people they have
zero regard for human life
I now recognize Mr Payne from New Jersey
thank you Mr chairman
ranking member
we're the most compassionate
generous
country in the West
tell that to the young people that are
still looking for their parents
that were separated
under the previous administration
Mr Beer
um
and I know my friends on the other side
don't like to hear it
um
but Fentanyl and other hard drugs are
smuggled through ports of Entry
into the U.S by
unfortunately U.S citizens
these drugs are usually hidden in
vehicles
cargo run a person in the hopes that it
won't be detected by CBP
um
as they process people
and goods into the country
what what policy changes can we make to
allow Personnel at ports of Entry to
focus on interdiction of drugs
well the most important policy change
that can be made in this area addresses
the demand for drugs
ultimately if U.S consumers are willing
to pay for illicit narcotics to come
into the country the black market will
supply it and we've seen that for the
last century of prohibition whether it's
alcohol prohibition whether it's drug
prohibition we have seen this phenomenon
and unfortunately during the pandemic
when we greatly restricted trade and
travel it forced the shift from heroin
to fentanyl which is a far more potent
and more deadly substance and so I do
not believe that there is a solution to
fentanyl smuggling at ports of Entry at
the end of the day the black market is
supplying drugs to U.S consumers who are
paying for it and as long as we focus on
Supply and ignore the drug war victims
and not address their needs not provide
them with options to protect themselves
against fentanyl wouldn't it be great if
fentanyl test strips were legalized
Nationwide so that people can know what
they're ingesting so they're not ending
up like victims that we've heard about
today we need options we need Physicians
to be able to to actually treat
Addiction in this country and not be
prohibited from from for example
prescribing methadone to their patients
so there are options out there I do not
believe that restricting trade and
travel and trying to crack down on
immigration or even on U.S citizens
travel abroad is the solution to the
pandemic of
of fentanyl poisonings
and so um
you you're saying that the demand is so
great
that there's always going to be
opportunities for people
to try to um
benefit on that is that correct
absolutely for example marijuana is
trafficked between ports of Entry we
know this has been the case for for
decades we we ended up uh during the
early 2000s increasing the border patrol
doubling the size of the border patrol
we doubled the amount of marijuana
seizures but the amount of marijuana in
the United States did not go down
because the difference in cost of
production in Mexico and elsewhere is so
low it's easy to just smuggle some more
and so it didn't work in fact it
backfired in that case as well because
marijuana potency according to the DEA
increased by more than 30 percent as a
result of that Crackdown so we see it
again and again and again crackdowns
produce higher potency drugs which are
more dangerous to drug users we need to
focus on protecting drug users not more
crackdowns not more border crackdowns
not more Banning of Asylum that's not
the answer to this problem
thank you and um with that Mr chairman
I'll yield back
gentleman yields back I now recognize Mr
guest from Mississippi uh thank you Mr
chairman uh shares chair guest chair
thank you uh for being with us today uh
seeing uh in your testimony uh you talk
specifically about fentanyl pills that
seizures were up 610 percent since 2020.
uh you heard Mr buyer just testify a few
moments ago that the solution to the
drug problem is we must protect drug
users
that the solution is we need to legalize
fentanyl strips
what in your opinion is the solution to
the drug problem is the solution not to
close the border to stop the drugs from
ever entering the country and not to try
to make it easier for people to use and
consume illegal drugs yes Mr guest uh I
I well I agree with you after curb
demand this is like mopping the bathroom
floor without turning off the tub water
you've got to turn off the tub water if
you're ever going to convert curb Demand
right now fentanyl is in Arizona is 16
percent higher than it was all of last
year so think about what that's going to
be by the end of this year
and let me ask you we just returned from
the border there was a group of 11
members of this committee who went to
the Border uh that is my fourth border
visit in approximately 18 months uh and
every time I've been to the Border
Sheriff I've heard these two statements
one is that it is the worst that the
Border has ever been the conditions of
the border both for uh immigrants coming
across the border human traffic
smuggling drug smuggling and also we
hear that those front line individuals
yourself federal law enforcement state
and local officials feel as though the
federal government has abandoned them
that this is no longer a federal problem
and now has dumped this problem in the
lapse of you and other local officials
let me ask you do you share that same
opinion uh that won the border is worse
than it's ever been in your history of
law enforcement and then two uh the
feeling that the federal government has
abandoned you and the the men and women
who serve under your command absolutely
it is far far worse than it's ever been
for us and I do share the opinion that
the federal government has abandoned us
we have no line of communication outside
of Arizona and we feel they've turned
their back on not only the border patrol
agents but they've sent a clear message
to us in law enforcement they're not
interested in solving this and every
effort that states like Arizona and
Texas make to try to fix this problem on
their end because the federal government
is failing they try to thwart that as
well so we do feel abandoned and let me
ask you sir if we know that in early May
title 42 will be ending title 42 under
the public health emergency has been a
way in which we've been able to return
immigrants to their country of origin
very quickly we know that DHS is his own
numbers there are internal numbers which
they've shared with us and which have
been shared publicly said that they
believe that as many as 14 000
immigrants a day will enter the country
uh once title 42 expires my public
school math 14 000 immigrants a day at
roughly 30 to 31 days depending on what
month you're looking at 425
000 immigrants a month last December was
the worst month we had ever had 250 000
uh and so we would be looking at adding
another 175
000 in addition to the 250 once title 42
goes away assuming that the numbers DHS
has provided is correct
what would that do to your community
well it will demolish our community and
it'll demolish communities like Yuma and
not just mine what happens in my
backyard today will be in your front
yard tomorrow no matter what state you
are in and explain that today a very
powerful statement what happens in your
backyard or today will affect our front
yards tomorrow explain that statement
please the estimate that 50 of all
illegal illegal drugs in America come
through Arizona's borders and I would
say that 90 of that comes through Pinal
County on the I-10 Interstate or I-8
interstate on its way to Phoenix then it
gets transported out to the other states
so when I say what happens in my
backyard today we'll be in your front
yard tomorrow that's what I refer to and
that's not just drugs it is also humans
being trafficked for slavery uh and let
me ask you this Sheriff we've had
testified before this committee before
secretary mayorkas has testified on
several occasions uh he's told both
myself and Congressman Bishop to my
right uh that the border secure uh he's
also said that in Senate hearings he
said that in interviews that he's given
to the media uh you there uh being just
50 some odd miles from the Southwest
border uh do you agree with that
assessment do you agree with secretary
mayorkus that the border is secure I'd
like to preface this first by saying I
tragically lost my son and my
granddaughter and my in in December in a
car accident I got a handwritten note
from uh secretary mayorkas which touched
my heart deeply but I do not agree with
his sentiment that the borders secure it
is not secure it's never been more
unsecure thank you Mr chairman I yield
back
I think it was German Miss Taylor first
of all I want to say my heart goes out I
pray for you and your family
back home fentanyl is touching everybody
that I know
I live in Santa Ana California we're
about 100 miles away from the border
it's touching us
you know just a few years back I was
having a conversation with my daughter I
was in high school
talked about drugs and she said Oh Daddy
the drugs all over the place in my high
school I said maybe I should send you to
the private school she said oh no Daddy
there's more drugs there because there's
more money there
drug abuse
bottom line we all have to come together
and make sure we don't lose another
death
that's what we have to work for
as I said I'm about 100 miles away from
the border
I've been to San Ysidro Tijuana border
crossing about four times in this last
year
I don't publicize it because my job is
to find what the facts are to make sure
we drill down and coming up with a
solution
when I was there Mr chairman I also saw
a couple of interesting drug busts saw a
woman being led from the border crossing
on foot from her car
she had a baby in her arms walking with
a five-year-old child
looked at the Port director and I said
what's that about he said we just
arrested her
truck full of drugs when I walked into
the holding area where the cells were
looked at another young lady also having
been arrested for a truck full of Narco
and they said this was an interesting
one that's a marine for service whose
life is about to change
I met with a port director I met with
officers in green and blue uniforms
and they had one basic message for all
of us give us the tools we need to do
our job
number one we've all known it for years
we don't have enough agents out there
they're suffering from morale issues why
because they do double shifts forced
double shift forced
they don't they need dogs to sniff out
the drugs the most effective technology
we have
are drug sniffing dogs they're not there
finally we have these neat things called
scanners
they said we need more of these so not
just on secondary but every car that
comes through that border is checked for
drugs
we've known what they need we just
haven't done our job of getting them the
resources
San Ysidro 99 of the trade through that
Port is good stuff we need to focus on
that one percent and Sheriff our
statistics are kind of there
Port director told me it in San Ysidro
depending on the timeline you measure
anywhere from 50 percent to 70 percent
of all drug seizures in one port San
Ysidro 70 percent
we know what the solution is let's fix
it
less than two minutes I've got left
Mr Beer
you talk about
immigration challenges I would say the
problem we have is at the border we have
a lot of challenges fentanyl drugs no
doubt
but we also have thing called refugees
all over the world right now it was down
there about six months nine months ago
look at the Ukrainian Refugee challenge
there is no more Ukrainian Refugee
challenge at the border because we fixed
how to take care of them now we have the
Russians at the border along with
everybody else
undocumented we have 11 million
undocumented workers in this country
many have been here 20 to 30 years
no hope of adjustment of status and the
AG area 50 percent 50 percent of all the
workers in the AG industry
undocumented let's Deport them all and
see what happens to our food chain
more workers Chamber of Commerce
Mr buyer I have a lot of questions but I
guess
would getting our border officers the
resources they're screaming for without
help stopping Fentanyl at the border
thank you of course it's going to allow
them to interdict more the most
important thing to do with the Asylum
crisis and to free up border Patrol's
resources so they can interdict as well
is to process people at ports of Entry
so doing double duty providing more
interesting that that's exactly what the
Border officers told me let us focus on
that one percent give us the tool thank
you very much Mr chair I yield
thank you the gentleman yields back I
now recognize Mr Bishop chairman Bishop
from North Carolina thank you Mr
chairman Mr Beer I guess I should say
congratulations
uh behold your handiwork
this is what you wanted this is what
you've advocated for for years
this is what the president wanted this
is what secretary mayorkas wanted what
minority members here have relentlessly
pursued
you've advocated an open and
uncontrolled border Mass immigration
you're in charge no no I certainly
haven't I don't know where you're
getting that where are you getting that
I'll ask you a question when I'm ready
quote something I will
um
Mr mayorkas has been willing to flout
U.S immigration law to achieve the mass
immigration that they and you favor
and know the migrants don't become
citizens in law but they certainly come
to the United States and they're
released into the United States
and and you consider that to be a good
thing because you think it will reduce
poverty and improve the the uh the
economy let me tell you how that works
there was an article in the New York
Times on Saturday I'm sure you read it
alone and exploited migrant children
work brutal jobs across the U.S
Carolina yoke who came to the United
States owners on her own last year to
live with a relative she had never met
the number of unaccompanied minors
entering the United States climbed to a
high of 130 000 last year three times
what it was five years earlier and this
summer is expected to bring another wave
guess what the federal government is
supposed to be in touch with them and
place them with sponsors through the
department of
Health and Human Services but although
the health and HHS calls the miners it
sends out a month after they go to live
with these sponsors many of whom they
don't know some of whom are sponsoring
20 children or more
the agency could not reach more than 85
000 children overall the agency lost
immediate contact with a third of
Migrant children by all means let's
bring more in so more end up in the
situation of Carolina
yoke probably
so what is it or you could go to the
article from last July smuggling
migrants at the border is now a billion
dollar business you say well it's
because they're illegal if they weren't
illegal then the Mexican cartels
wouldn't be able to charge them the fees
that generate 15 billion dollars in
revenues I'd like to ask you how you
understand that if they have the
pervasive control of the Mexican side
that the border patrol tells me they
have how come they couldn't continue to
charge the fees that they're torturing
people over and placing children in
indentured servitude in the United
States why couldn't they continue to do
that in a failed Narco state in Mexico
well we actually have experience with
legal immigration of Mexicans in Central
America
why
we have h2a guest worker programs that
allow people to come and they're not
controlled by the cartels we should
expand those guest worker programs and
allow people to come legally my question
sir and my question to you if I'm not
going to let you filibuster my time I'm
going to let you answer me this question
you attacked me
I'm going to let you answer my question
if you answer my question but that
question is what would prevent cartels
from charging legal immigrants if they
were coming across in Mass
well because we already have experience
with this sir we have legal immigration
it's just extremely unusual and
constrained we have no year-round guest
worker
programs I've asked the question twice
you don't want to answer it that's fine
that's legal let me say this let me say
this
in January of this year in January 5 in
Korea con
there was open Warfare between the
Mexican military and the Sinaloa
cartella's the Mexican military sought
to arrest
or video Guzman
they burn cars they had a Sinaloa
soldiers running around on Narco tanks
firing 50 caliber weapons at military
aircraft in the air
that's a cartel that you are
strengthening with your ideology sir and
the members of this committee the
minority who have adequated advocated
for this relentlessly and the president
of the United States and secretary
mayorkas and if you think it can occur
in the United States just keep going you
can come back then when you're Pro when
your Advocates you know the other thing
you said that's remarkable to me is to
think what you think we need to do is
have more legalization of fentanyl
across the United States that sounds
like a great plan I'd suggest you go
read San Francisco by Michael
schellenberger about what's happened in
that City
it is outrageous
it is is misguided as any policy I've
ever seen in the history of mankind and
in the name of humanity
I don't want to hear any more of your
economic arguments I'm concerned about
Carolina yoke and those other people
who've been distributed across the
country to people they don't know to
homes that don't care for them to go
work in factories as as children
that's not the way it's supposed to be
but it is the result of what you have
advocated my time's expired it's not the
result of what I've advocated at all
gentleman's time has expired I now
recognize Mr thanodar from Michigan
thank you thank you Mr chairman
my colleagues across the aisle have
focused almost single-handedly on the
southern border today
we have heard very little about
challenges we face at our northern
border
which is more than twice as long as our
Southern border and critical to our
economy
in my district in Michigan
many businesses and individuals rely on
being able to travel and ship goods
regularly across the border
ensuring Customs and Border Protection
has the personnel and resources needed
to keep ports of Entry open and process
people and goods efficiently is
essential
unfortunately a shortage of Pathways for
immigration
has made our borders very difficult to
manage
CBP has had to rely on temporary Duty
assignments to Surge
employees where they are most needed
which has often pulled resources away
from the northern border
as an immigrant myself
I'm a proud example of how immigrants
contribute to American society
I was fortunate to have the opportunity
to come to the United States to pursue
my PhD in chemistry and then gain
citizenship
as a business owner I have created
hundreds of jobs and helped Drive
Innovations
unfortunately this American dream is
available too far too few
our immigration system remains extremely
restrictive despite a major need for
workers among American businesses
even worse
we often hear rhetoric
scapegoating immigrants for increasing
crime and taking American jobs when all
available evidence shows that immigrants
in fact make us safer and grow our
economy when I was applying for a
student visa
my Visa was denied four times
and at the fifth time when I introduced
the same papers that they denied the
fourth time they approved my Visa when I
asked why the Visa officer changed her
mind
I was told that she was in America on
her vacation and another agent looked at
my papers and approved them
I'm glad you didn't give up sir yes Mr
Beer would expanding Pathways for legal
immigration make it easier for CBP to
manage the southern border and in turn
allow for more personnel and resources
to focus on the Northern
border as well oh absolutely we've
already seen it in in action with the
Ukrainian crisis we had tens of
thousands of ukrainians showing up we
created a parole process for them so
they can fly directly from Europe to the
United States with with U.S sponsorship
that program has worked great they
expanded it to Venezuela and Haiti and
Nicaragua and Cuba it's also reducing
the number of crossings from those
countries now that we have a legal
immigration process set up for them
just give you one other example there
was a story about an Afghan who showed
up at our border we hear about these
people who travel thousands and
thousands of miles to get here he won
the diversity Visa Lottery he had the
opportunity to come legally and as a
result of the pandemic they shut down
all the Visa processing so he never got
his green card and then he showed up at
our Southern border so the consequences
of restricting legal immigration are
real for our border communities and if
we can get legal immigration right we
can fix this problem we need people
you're absolutely right
thank you Mr Beer and I yield back
gentlemen Neons I now recognize Mr
Jimenez from Florida
thank you Mr chairman and on
on January 29th I had a meeting uh with
secretary mayorkas where I asked a a
number of simple questions he was upset
that I was amazed that he didn't have
the answer but he said he had the answer
right at his fingertips so on the 31st I
sent him a letter saying according to
U.S Customs and Border Protection over
4.5 million migrants encounters have
occurred at the Southwest border since
President Biden took office how many of
those individuals encountered are
currently residing in the United States
and where are they reciting what is the
process for choosing location to release
individuals and what sort of information
is given to those local authorities
second question how many of these
individuals have authorized work permits
permits do those who receive work
permits receive federal government
assistance if so how many and how much
per individual do those individuals who
do not have authorized work permits
receive federal government assistance if
so how many and how much per individual
and finally according to CBP sources
over 1.2 million known godaways have
evaded the CBP how many of those have
since been located by CVP what are the
current steps being taken by a
Department of Homeland Security and
processing individuals who have been
captured and detained and how many
immigrants who were unknown to DHS have
been detained and departed over the past
two years he said he had all that
information I asked for the the answer
to come back in about a week I've sent
this in January 31st Mr chairman I've
yet to receive a response from something
that apparently they had at their
fingertips but luckily for me today I
got a call from a friend of mine who has
some of the answers and here are some of
the answers and he said that he was
speaking to a friend of ours or a friend
of his down in Miami who's recently sent
twenty thousand dollars to Cuba to have
a migrant come over to Mexico
and then they were transported across
the borders so it was twenty thousand
dollars when the migrant came across he
was immediately given a cell phone
uh he was given a plane ticket and he
was given sixteen hundred dollars a
month for six months in federal
assistance and now since he hasn't
answered me now I gotta multiply 4.7
million times sixteen hundred dollars
times six months the uh it's costing the
U.S taxpayer uh
something north of 45 billion dollars
so it's a it definitely impacted uh you
know the United States of America and I
want to shift uh shift gears here and
Miss uh Miss reisling I I really
sympathize with with what happened to
you personally uh I had a a death in my
family about four years ago from drug
overdoses I used to be a paramedic in
the city of Miami
uh where you know we saw a lot of drug
overdoses due to heroin never saw
anything like Fentanyl and a deadly you
know the dead deadly kind of a drug that
fentanyl is now you're absolutely right
fentanyl has killed uh drug overdoses
have skyrocketed over a hundred thousand
Americans probably per year are dying of
fentanyl now can you imagine if a
foreign adversary came across the border
every single day killed 200 Americans
and then scurried back you know across
the border
um
how we would react to something like
that well it's happening every single
day and we have a terrorist
organizations which are the Mexican drug
cartels which are profiting immensely
from Human Trafficking or before in the
Trump Administration they made about 500
million dollars a year now they're
making 13 billion dollars a year on
human trafficking but worse than that
they're killing Americans
foreign
you know about uh you know over a little
bit over 20 years ago a terrorist
organization came over killed about 3
000 Americans and we went and traveled
15 000 miles in wage 15 years of war to
get rid of that terrorist organization
we're doing absolutely nothing about a
terrorist organization that's killing
far more Americans every single year
um and we're doing nothing about it and
so you know I um I asked the Secretary
of uh the I'm sorry the director of the
FBI if he considered them to be a
terrorist organization and I can't I
guess because of some bureaucracy we
just can't label them a terrorist
organization but um you know we should
be doing a heck of a lot more we should
be making them pay for what they're
doing to us and while I agree of an all
and above solution to our drug problem
here with the users Etc uh I also think
that the people are supplying that
weapon that's killing a hundred thousand
Americans every year need to pay the
price and thank you I yield my time back
gentleman yields uh will now recognize
Mr swalwell from California for his uh
five minutes chairman if it's okay with
you actually I was going to let Mr Ivy
go ahead of me and then I'll go the next
round and go to that Minister I came
here okay uh chair recognizes Mr Ravi
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
ranking member thank you Congressman
swallow well I I appreciate the chance
to uh address the the committee on this
today I
um
heard a lot of comments this morning uh
negligent homicide perhaps a military
strike in Central America as are two of
the things I've heard I I'm not ready to
go there I must say and I hope the
United States isn't there either I think
um Mr Beer I appreciate your testimony
I'll come back to you in a moment but
one point I wanted to make initially and
with the chart here behind me
is that there are things we can do short
of military options or you know trying
to prosecute the secretary for negligent
homicide and the Democrats have already
taken steps to do that so with respect
to the the Omni Omnibus Bill which is
behind me it's in the blue chart you can
see it up on the monitor those are the
amounts that we've passed last Congress
I wasn't here yet but that was an
Omnibus Bill and I say we
based on Democrats we had 216 Democrats
voted for this bill
um only nine Republicans joined in I
don't think any of them are on this
committee
um 200 Republicans voted against it so
the talk we're hearing about the things
that need to happen and get done part of
that goes to the need to have resources
to address it like more border agents
for example Mr Korea talked about the
need for
surveillance at the border the ability
to check vehicles as they come across
ports of entry and as Mr Bill is your
testimony points out I think it's like
86 86 percent of the the Fentanyl and
narcotics come across through points of
Entry as opposed to the other border
areas so why don't we focus on that well
the bill we pass helps to do that and we
can go through all of these I'm I'm
short on time but the point I want to
make is on the left side
under the blue is the money that was
passed and the Omnibus Bill primarily by
Democratic votes the red side is uh the
Republican legislation that's been
offered I just mentioned most
Republicans voted against the on bus
bill that passed last year and is
actually sending resources to the border
to help address many of these issues and
I know the Biden Administration has said
that more is going to come when the the
budget proposal comes out on March 9th
under the red though as you can see um
it's gook's eggs all the way down the
page
and that comes from H.R 29 which was
supposedly the Republican leadership
bill on addressing this issue and just
for those of you that don't know the
leadership bills are supposed to be
statements of that party's Focus these
are top priority bills we need to pass
these things to address the key problems
facing the American people and so I
picked HR 29 because that was designated
by House Republicans we looked at other
bills too and they haven't put out any
money for that either that we that we
can find but I thought HR 29 was
representative and they call it the
Border Safety and Security Act of 2023.
they put up no funds for any of the
types of things in the programs you all
are talking about are challenges I I
know you have different views about what
the cause of the problems are and all of
that but I think almost all of them
require additional resources so you know
from that old movie uh I forget Jerry
Maguire I think it was show me the money
uh your budget shows your priorities the
budget priorities stated by the
Republican caucus so far is that they
want to talk about let me get this right
um
Prosecuting Mr mayorkas for negligent
homicide they want to talk about
removing Mr mayorkas from office but
fixing the Border crisis which I what I
thought this was hearing was going to be
about we don't get much conversation
about that Mr Beer I've only got a
minute let me come to you quickly with
we just talked a moment ago about the 86
percent of U.S citizens are actually
carrying the fennel across the border is
that right that's right in 2021 this one
page seven of his testimony by the way
your testimony had 115 footnotes so in
contrast to a lot of the episodic and
you know that kind of stuff your
testimony is clearly documented with
data which I think is an important way
to figure out what sort of policies we
should be enacting 90 93 of the fentanyl
that was seized came through ports of
Entry is that correct that's right with
respect to the the legalization you were
accused of wanting to legalize fentanyl
I didn't see that in anything you wrote
I did see you talk about Lee's light
legalizing fentanyl test strips is that
part that's right legalizing test strips
would enable drug users to make sure
that they are not taking fentanyl which
would have prevented the deaths that
we're hearing about today yeah by the
way we've had some of those deaths in
Maryland we're not on the border but
Prince George's County where I'm from
Montgomery County Mr trone and I put a
he put a bill together to address that
in part I support it I believe it's a
bipartisan Bill hopefully the corrupt
Republicans on the committee will
support that as well I see I've run out
of my time I'll come back though I want
to talk to you about
the impact of what you've seen in
Venezuela Cuba and Nicaragua from an
immigration standpoint and the change in
the legislation that that really
addressed the problem there in the ways
that you're talking about thank you Mr
chairman is inspired I now recognize
Miss Green from Georgia
thank you Mr chairman we have one job in
the federal government and that is to
protect the United States of America our
national security and all Americans
their life their Liberty and their
Pursuit of Happiness and since the Biden
Administration has taken over there has
been a direct result in the number of
deaths in this country from Fentanyl
I want you to know that in 2020 there
were 4.8 thousand pounds of fentanyl
Seas by CBP
but in 2021 fiscal year 2021 it
increased to 11.2
000 pounds of fentanyl was seized by the
CBP that is a direct result of Biden
Administration failure policies
now here we are in to date to date
fiscal year 2023 they have already
received or seized 12.5
000 pounds of Fentanyl
the Biden Administration is failing this
country by not protecting our border and
securing our border and stopping Chinese
fentanyl from being brought into our
country illegally by the cartels and
people are dying every single day
because of it fentanyl deaths have
doubled doubled
between two years from April 2019 to
April 2021 those are the statistics we
have going fentanyl deaths doubled from
754 to 64
178. this is a this is a complete
failure
I want you to know it's affecting every
single state in the country
in Georgia Georgia fentanyl deaths have
gone up by 230 percent in rural
Northwest Georgia my district the 14th
District we are up
350 percent
Bill does not discriminate on your skin
color your gender your politics fentanyl
kills everyone it kills police officers
First Responders and tragically fentanyl
is now the number one cause of death of
Young Americans ages 18 to 45.
and this is Unforgivable
the Biden Administration is responsible
for this and they have blood on their
hands because they refuse to secure our
border
today we today we have a witness with us
miss kiesling
I just want to tell you I'm so sorry
from one mother to another
for the death of your two sons
that that died from fentanyl poisoning
that should never have happened should
never have happened to you it should
never happen to any family it happens to
families at home where I live it happens
to pretty much everyone we know and I
want to ask you and first I want to
thank you for being brave to come here
and share your grief with our committee
but
Miss kiesling would your sons be alive
today if the if our government would
secure our Southern border
the year Caleb was born 2000 there were
20 000 drug related deaths
and the year they died it was five times
as many
and I appreciate you using the term
fentanyl poisoning because that's what
it was it wasn't an overdose they had no
idea that they were doing anything that
could kill them and it's because
fentanyl got into this country and I
heard this man over here from the Kano
Institute you know talk about well it's
because of demand what I'm hearing him
say is they asked for it
the hell seriously are you kidding me we
need to protect our children they didn't
ask for that this wasn't demand that
they wanted the fennel they didn't want
fentanyl they thought they were getting
Percocets
okay he's absolutely clueless like total
disconnect from what's Happening
um you know and to say oh let's just
give them strips or let's give them
rehab well you know what my kids got the
federal my son Caleb went to Federal
rehab it was a flop house it was a real
rehab you're wasting your money where
you're sending it I'm telling you it's a
waste of money because it wasn't real
rehab and the government paid for their
drugs under covid
they encouraged them not to stay home
all these young people in our support
groups we all talk about it how they
paid for their drugs with the federal
funds under covid
that gave them incentive not to work
healthy young people
thank you miss kiesling this government
has failed you and it's failing American
families and it's failing most of all
it's failing our children and our young
people
thank you very much time has expired I
now recognize Mr swalwell from
California thank you chairman
start with uh Sheriff lamb thank you sir
for your service in a very hard and
challenging part of the country and I've
got two brothers who are Deputy sheriffs
my dad was deputy sheriff I know it's a
thankless job
uh and I guess I just want to ask if you
had
20 000 more
border patrol agents surged across the
southern border would that make it
easier or harder for you to do your job
thank you Mr swallow for the kind words
as well and for your family service
absolutely 20 000 more border patrol
agents would make our world a difference
I would love more deputies too so yes
Staffing does matter
and if you were able to have
more Technologies whether it's drone
Technologies sensor Technologies to work
with CBP to Monitor and track the Border
would that also help yes sir we spent a
lot of money on helicopter fuel we spent
a lot of resources there where I'm at if
I have a regular drone I have to be with
line of sight honestly in my area I need
a drone that's a military style drone
that I can fly for 50 miles so would
love to have a drone
and do you agree that
we need to crack down on any employer
who hires an undocumented individual
because by hiring somebody who's
undocumented it incentivizes migration
I've heard a lot of talk about a lot of
things but I think we're underestimating
the amount of lost tax revenue that goes
on every year from all the people in the
country illegally we are all paying
taxes and we're footing the bill for a
lot of things there's a lot of lost tax
revenue I do agree that on some levels
there should be some crackdowns but we
also need to balance that out with the
amount of employment that is needed in
this country this is your job this is
what you guys are good at and uh you
know and respectfully I would say the
last two years
one party had command of congress senate
and the presidency and could have passed
an immigration Bill and didn't do so and
now here we are again now back where
both parties are split so I think
there's a lot of help and you're right
in
four years before that another party had
exactly what you described and and I
don't want to disvalue the benefit of an
immigrant Workforce because my next
point is that wouldn't you agree that
having a legal immigration system uh
where people who go through the legal
process go to the front of the line
would be a preferred way to adjudicate
those who want to come to the United
States follow the rules work pay those
taxes 100 agree I've lived in the
Philippines I've lived in Panama I lived
in Argentina I agree that you have to
create a common sense path to fill jobs
to give these people an opportunity me
along with every other law enforcement
all these people set up here we want
people to come here and make a better
life we just want them to follow the
process that's right and and what I just
described to you was essentially the
2014 President Obama Republican deal in
the Senate where 68 Republicans and
Democrats agreed on the framework that I
just laid out it's my hope that we can
get back to that because I agree with
you I think most Americans they want to
have a border that is safe and secure
they want to have you know immigrants
come to this country and and work the
jobs that have a necessity to be filled
they want to make sure that there's a
background check and that the legal
process are the ones that go to the
front of the line and it seems to be
that you know the politics of this
overtakes the solutions
um on the point of fentanyl Miss
Keystone I truly wanted
to share my sympathy for you and your
family someone who knows people who have
also died
um
but I believe that the biggest culprit
here and I I think the Republican
colleagues of mine agree uh is really
going after China uh I think China has
blood on its hands I don't think
President Biden has blood on his hands I
think China has blood on its hands for
the fentanyl crisis because as number of
people have said
overwhelmingly these fentanyls coming
through points of entry and
overwhelmingly it's U.S citizens and the
fentanyl we know is coming from over in
China and I think internationally we
should all work to apply more pressure
on China to account for what it's doing
uh and finally I think Miss green is
just divorced from reality when she
wants to use the fentanyl seizures as a
way to beat up on the president because
Sheriff lamb you said earlier today that
you were literally saving the country
with the number of people that you have
saved with those seizures and where I
come from and my brothers make a big
seizure that get guns and drugs off the
streets we don't use that to make a
political point we use that to give an
attaboy uh you know to the police
officers for what they did and so I'm
going to give y'all an attaboy for what
you've done and thank you because you've
taken a lot of fentanyl off the streets
and you've made us a lot safer because
you've done it yield back thank you Mr
swallow
gentleman's Tom has expired we recognize
Mr Gonzalez from Texas for five minutes
of question
uh thank you chairman I'm a retired Navy
Master Chief I spent 20 years in the
military I spent five years in Iraq and
Afghanistan I fought in two Wars I know
what war looks like I know what war
smells like I know what war feels like
we are at War we are at war with China
we every single day I just got back from
Taiwan I spent 10 days in the Pacific uh
every single day China attacks us via
cyber and our allies every single day
China partners with drug cartels and
they poison our children with fentanyl
this is intentional you see it over and
over again uh and we got to act like
we're at War we can't have a presidency
that views it as competition it's not
competition when China is killing our
children it's not competition when China
is poisoning our country my first
question is uh to sheriff lamb uh you
know Arizona is very similar to Texas
this is our third year of this crisis I
feel as if Arizona is about a year
behind especially in some of the rural
areas I know my my uh my good friend
Juan ciscomani is working on this issue
uh but one of the questions I have for
you is uh I've got to build a Security
First Act that that designates cartels
as terrorist organizations in your
opinion do you think cartels are
terrorizing migrants absolutely uh you
can ask the people that have been
decapitated chopped to Pieces enslaved
in the sex trade the families who have
lost loved ones that strikes Terror into
the fear of a lot of people and the
people that live along that border so
that it would be the definition of a
terrorist organization and I agree that
they would qualify as one you know ever
literally every single day I get a text
message or I get a call from my
constituents saying things are out of
control yesterday I got a a picture of
of imagine if you're in your back
imagine if you're in your house and five
people walk through your yard not who
cares if they're American citizens or
not they walk through your area right
they they intrude on your area uh my
question to you is what is happening in
Arizona because it seems it's starting
to get more traction people are starting
to see what is happening in other parts
of the Texas or other parts of the
country outside of Texas but once again
the the terror for us has not stopped
and and what I'm seeing is our
constituents the people that I represent
in Del Rio in Eagle Pass I mean earlier
today I was with a a gentleman named Mr
King from Del Rio that was walking me
through it he goes hey Tony I got two
young kids three and five-year-olds and
every day I'm under this this attack
what is happening in Arizona well the
ranchers can't even let their kids out
on their own to ride the range
um we have you know we have families
that are concerned every day my son fell
into an addiction with fentanyl luckily
he overcame it and was clean before he
ended up passing away in a traffic
accident this is affecting every
American family and arizonans are not
immune from that
uh my next question LCD sheriff is um
this is what I've seen too is the cartel
manipulates our legal legal system and
I'm very concerned with unaccompanied
children this is something that really
isn't getting a lot of attention uh I'm
curious if you've come across any
situations where folks were connecting
with a fake parent if you will uh I know
I know a lot of that falls in the border
patrol area but when it comes to
unaccompanied children what are you
seeing in Arizona yeah I'm part of the
alliance I'm the chairman for the
alliance to combat transnational threats
where we work with our federal partners
and I will tell you contrary to a common
belief the majority of children are
being separated by the cartels not by
the American government we had I believe
130 000 unaccompanied minors last year
alone and they are many cases being
released back to cartel members because
there's no way for them to know where
they came from or prove that these are
family members so it's absolutely
happening and and they're taking
advantage like you said of our policies
here they're very astute to what we
believe and what we're trying to do I
sit on my next question is in regards to
funding one of my colleagues brought up
funding earlier I sit on the
Appropriations Committee and operation
stone garden funds is an area of look
money will never solve this problem
throw in more money at the problem
doesn't solve it but if you put if you
put resources towards areas that work
you can tackle the problem correctly I
pushed for three years to increase
operation stone garden funds uh like I
said that program needs to be refined
they need to kind of take the gloves off
allow them to do some things but can you
speak to operation stone garden how is
that I know in Texas one of our counties
in Brewster county uh Sheriff Dotson he
was able to add an extra Deputy uh you
know we we in that area he he represents
it's larger than Delaware imagine
getting extra Deputy but how is it in
Arizona with stone garden funds we
appreciate operation stone garden we uh
it gives us the ability to work with
border patrol on a daily basis it funds
my helicopter my fuel and all these
things that we not only use for border
security but we use for search and
rescue to save not only Smugglers left
behind but to save other citizens that
have been hurt while they're hiking or
whatever thank you Sheriff chairman I'll
yield back
foreign
thank you so very much and I certainly
do appreciate
the leadership of my ranking member over
the decades I can almost say and
certainly hope that you will join him uh
as I know you have great leadership as
well and we have spoken about some
issues that we want to work on uh just
for the record Mr chairman we are
crafting and Fentanyl bill that we hope
will draw a bipartisan support and we'll
be happy to share it with this committee
and the Committees that I'm working with
along with the ranking member to the
witnesses let me uh thank you for the
sacrifice that you've made to even be
here today
if we didn't have the opportunity to
speak to the American people we would
not have the opportunity to be guided by
the American people because we are
public servants I certainly want to say
to Mrs kieselin and I hope I'm with
adequate pronunciation that you have my
deepest sympathy
to have the loss and to experience what
you've experienced and we make a promise
here as I've done sitting on this
committee that we will put you first and
we will find every solution that we can
to keep dangerous criminals but also to
ensure the protection of the American
people so my deepest sympathy to you and
I thank you your story is needed in this
room uh today I also want to thank
Sheriff lamb for certainly representing
law enforcement Across America
we all have law enforcement in our
communities and I can assure you they
are our neighbors as well as our
protectors I just came back from the
border briefly with a senatorial
delegation
and talk to the men and women at CBP
stood by as in fact walked to
the point of demarcation between the
United States and Mexico watched
individuals with uh day passes I'll just
use that as a as a a parochial term
coming legally across but at the same
time watching canines and also being
shown a small vehicle driven by an
American young woman unfortunately that
was loaded down uh with drugs I think in
this instance marijuana
the CBP felt very comfortable with their
ability
to detect uh and to find the amount of
drugs coming through the legal points of
Entry my concern was this young woman 19
now has got a life ruined they even said
to me she probably got a hundred dollars
I'm hoping not I'm just stunned that she
was not in college or somewhere else
that would have been more productive but
I think it sets the right the narrative
that is actually the facts of what we
need to deal with in keeping
um the borders safe and we know that we
have a very extensive border what you
see in San Diego you may not seeing Yuma
you may not see in El Paso you may not
see in Brownsville Laredo and otherwise
so I want to
um
uh indicate that first of all the app is
weight is working
uh not out of my uh speculative lips if
you will but out of experts that are at
the board it is working uh it is
challenging you have to have the right
the languages you have to make sure
people have access to it uh have um are
in places where they can actually
connect but all teams have set up
individuals handling the apps more
resources are needed for those handling
the apps and receiving the information
uh but that process seems to have a
submerit so I see this have secretary
mayorkas in here and let me
um compliment the secretary for being an
immigrant uh and Rising uh from his uh
meager Beginnings uh and serving us with
great passion and assertiveness and
firmness about securing the American
Border I want to go to you uh Dr Byers
um our colleague Congressman Ivy offered
a a wonderful
um
array of um support that we gave to the
system of immigration
1.88 billion dollars that Democrats did
and I remember about 2004 I offered and
worked with then Senator Kerry
for a a major contribution so I only
have about 10 seconds left let me ask
you
about the Democrats approach but more
importantly that one question about our
migrant mothers and children bringing
over drugs to make us unsafe or is there
another scheme that is being used to
bring over those drugs I'll yield to you
right Asylum Seekers are not bringing
drugs they're the ones we heard about
who turn themselves in who request
Asylum you're talking about the ones who
are waiting at ports of Entry to be able
to use a phone app in order to apply for
Asylum they're not bringing drugs either
we need a process for them to free up
law enforcement resources to interdict
people who are coming to do harm do you
believe that this uh process that
Governor Abbott is using four billion
dollars and putting the National Guard
at the border uh is enhancing any great
safety in that particular small area
would you just give a general assessment
on that
Sharon you're very gracious I'm sorry I
read the clock wrong I'm so sorry so
sorry look very very quickly I I think
ultimately uh what the Texas governor
has to deal with is is very difficult
situation but we are seeing a lot of
people being arrested for very minor
crimes and being locked up they're not
getting into the immigration process as
they should and and are entitled to unto
our own laws I thank the gentleman I
thank the chairman
foreign
for an academic curriculum for our
military Dodge schools that's based on
the the life of Martin Luther King I
appreciate your partnership in that
um
I now recognize Mr lalota from New York
thank you chairman I want to say thanks
to our Witnesses for being here
especially to you Miss Keith link for
Having the courage to share your story
I'm the father of three wonderful
daughters and I couldn't imagine what
you've gone through so I appreciate you
sharing that with us hopefully it
provides us the perspective and the
courage as well to tackle this problem
as well
I represent a Suburban District on Long
Island where about 2 000 miles north of
the Southern border but because of the
country's open borders and my state
Sanctuary City policies New York state
has to become a border state but just
this past week I had the opportunity to
visit the Border down in El Paso to
witness firsthand what is going on with
the 1.2 million gotaways the 100 000
fentanyl poisons that we've had over the
past year
1.2 million gotaways that's more people
than eight different states and the
reality is our federal government has no
idea where these people are but what we
do know is that 100 000 people died from
fentanyl poisonings last year and that's
250 per day the equivalent of a
commercial airliner crashing every day
and we know that that fentanyl is being
made in China and being smuggled across
the U.S Mexico border and Sheriff lamb
you noted that the impact of the Border
crisis isn't just in your state isn't
just in the United States border states
but across the United States and in my
home county of Suffolk like I said 2 000
miles north of the Southern border we
saw 400 recently we saw 400 deaths due
to fentanyl poisoning I think that we
all agree that more must be done to stop
these illegal substances from entering
our communities so my question is to you
Sheriff what resources do you need to
find and seize the illegal drugs that
are coming across our borders that we
can best fight this Scourge that is
killing so many Americans and what
impact if any in your opinion would a
wall or a fence or other physical
barrier do to help you do your job sir
I'll answer the second thing first the
wall absolutely works I mean I have a
wall around my house it's not stopping
anybody but it's certainly deterring
them from coming into my yard it is a
piece of border security we got to put
that together with the right amount of
personnel the right equipment all of
that works together to do it my County
will always have a problem because we
have an Indian Reservation that actually
goes into Mexico there will be they
won't build a wall there so even in the
good times we still have people coming
through what we could do is continue to
fund or increase the funding for stone
garden it gives us the ability to really
help border patrol and I would love to
see a lot more equipment available for
local law enforcement to be able to do
it for us it's still going out and doing
it the old-fashioned way and that's
traffic stops and getting people that
are trying to be trafficked through the
deserts the cartels activities through
there can you speak Sheriff at all to
any of the technology that you could use
to help do that job better sir
absolutely thank you sir I would love to
have a drone a drone that was a military
type drone because you have the expanse
I need one that flies 50 to 100 miles
that we can monitor our desert areas
because within the desert areas south of
my county is where the cartels are
pushing people who have criminal records
I don't know if most people know in the
last year I think it's the last year
even if it was two years there's been
over 40 000 people apprehended that had
criminal convictions here in America for
crimes and that they are also wanted by
law enforcement so think about the
amount of people that are getting by us
that we're not that are actually
criminals already and thank you for your
dedication to this issue Sheriff it
matters to your county but it matters
Way North in my County as well chairman
I'll yield back
the gentleman yields I now recognize Mr
magaziner from Rhode Island
thank you chairman
um and if you'll indulge me this is my
first time uh speaking on this committee
so I'm going to just speak for a moment
at a high level uh my hope is that this
committee will work together on a
bipartisan basis to enact smart policies
to protect Americans against anyone who
would do us harm including by improving
our security at our borders and points
of Entry
everyone on this committee is going to
have a decision to make
whether we are going to work together to
get things done
or if we're here for partisan
grandstanding this committee as I
understand it has a reputation for being
one of the more bipartisan committees in
Congress historically where members do
work across the aisle in in the interest
of protecting the safety of the American
people and I hope that will continue
that's one of the reasons that I chose
to join this committee as a freshman
um
is disappointing to me that already I
hear not all not most but a few members
using their time to take shots at the
other side or the president or other
political figures instead of having a
productive conversation about Solutions
and and I hope that will not be the tone
going forward because there are plenty
of things that we can do to improve
Safety and Security at the border that I
think we can all agree on we should all
agree on securing the border and ports
of Entry by improving technology by
making sure there are adequate resources
available by finding ways to collaborate
across agencies and with friendly
Nations to crack down on human
trafficking drug smuggling and cartel
activity making the Asylum process more
efficient so that those who are doing
the right thing and looking to do the
process the right way don't run into a
wall of unnecessary red tape and delays
in addressing the root causes of
migration that are causing the vast
majority of people to come here
we also have a real and pressing crisis
with the opioid epidemic and
particularly fentanyl that is ravaging
our country and we should attack that
problem where it exists I'm glad that
there's been discussion today about the
fact that uh over the last couple years
more than 90 percent of fentanyl
seizures have occurred at legal ports of
entry with American citizens
unfortunately making up more than 80
percent of those apprehended I don't say
that to point fingers at anyone I just
say that to make sure that we focus our
time and attention on where the problems
are most severe so that we can save the
most lives
so we need to do everything that we can
to ensure that we stop Fentanyl and
other drug trafficking by employing the
technology and the Manpower where it's
needed the most
and at the same time we can't lose sight
of the fact that the vast majority of
migrants who are coming here seeking
entry to the United States at the
southern border are doing so because
they are fleeing violence and
persecution these are human beings who
are running away from something in the
vast majority of cases and they deserve
to be treated with humanity and respect
those are our national values so I hope
as a committee
we will endeavor to work together in a
sober way to address these and the other
challenges that our homeland faces I
hope that going forward we will not lose
sight of the fact that the intelligence
Community has been clear that domestic
extremism is one of our other most
serious threats over the last three
years 80 Americans have been killed by
violence motivated by domestic extremism
with white supremacy and anti-government
extremism being among the most common
motivating factors
that we need to redouble our efforts to
strengthen our infrastructure and our
cyber security
we just saw in the last few weeks
reports
of Vladimir Putin's regime attempting to
shut down the electric grids and LNG
facilities through Tiber attacks in this
country in the wake of the invasion of
Ukraine a year ago that is a sobering
reminder of how much damage can be done
to our country if we let our guard down
so this work is important we owe it to
the American people to focus on all of
the threats to the Homeland including
those at the southern border and I look
forward to working with my colleagues to
do just that
um
just expanding on the fentanyl crisis Dr
Beyer I I would ask you once again in
your judgment
where is
the biggest source of the problem from a
Homeland Security point of view and what
can we do as a committee on a bipartisan
basis to stop the flow of these deadly
substances into our country
well the heart of the problem is that
the ports of entry and we know this from
a lot of different lines of evidence
first of all we have a very large sample
size of people who've been interdicted
Crossing illegally and those people are
bringing hardly anything fentanyl wise
into the country the other thing to look
at is it's not that border patrol cannot
interdict drug traffickers for example
marijuana 75 percent of marijuana
arrests or or seizures occur between
ports of entry and that's because the
drug is too bulky in most cases to bring
it through the ports dea's own
investigations have found that it comes
through ports of Entry they testified
the vast majority come through legal
ports of entry and we also know because
the the cartels themselves are telling
us this because they're warring over
control of the ports of Entry they would
not be fighting a war over the control
of a Port of Entry if it was not the
most valuable place for drugs to enter
the country
gentleman yields back and I now
recognize Mr bikin of Oklahoma
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you to
the witnesses
um thank you for the impassion plea to
change a A system that is leading to the
death of hundreds of thousands of
Americans
um as we've talked about today this is
something that's impacting all of us
I've got a young adult that I was close
to many years ago he was actually a part
of my church youth group and I got word
two weeks ago that he had
threw an addiction sad addiction I've
not been around the show man for years
he had actually overdosed two weeks ago
and within you know a text message
exchange of condolences to his father he
you know the father's response was
nobody should have to go through this
and so missing no nobody should have to
go through what you're you're
experiencing
um in 2021 there were 299 fitting all
over those deaths in my state of
Oklahoma
in 2018 that figure was only 39 to your
point earlier that's a staggering almost
700 increase in and um and we know it's
attributed to what's happening to the
southern border just this month an
illegal alien pled guilty for an illegal
drug operation in Tulsa Oklahoma with 3
500 grams of fentanyl powder 1300 grams
of fentanyl pills were discovered from
his home and that's enough to kill all
the residents of Oklahoma City 650 000
people
two weeks ago a young man
as I described
um you know that I was close two years
ago passed away it hits home in addition
to that in my district in Bartlesville
Oklahoma there was a 21 year old named
Zach Sanders experimenting with pills
took a pill laced with fentanyl and he
died of a drug overdose in in January 21
and after his death his mother sponsored
a billboard in that City in Bartlesville
with a photo of Zach and the words that
said check your pills fentanyl kills
um
you know
what's happening is astounding
Bartlesville Police Department the city
had 12 overdose cases in 2021 and in
just the first 10 months of 2022 they
had 53 confirmed overdose cases and We
Know by the national statistics the
majority of deaths 18 to 45 years of age
is fentanyl and the the the climb of
overdoses in the correlation of fentanyl
I'm going to hold up a graphic here it's
a penny and Sheriff Leon this is a
question to you
um you know from from what we know it's
two milligrams which is demonstrated
here of fentanyl sized against the the
penny that's technically a lethal dose
enough to kill
um and we know that last year 13 000
pounds 13 000 pounds of fentanyl was was
seized in 2023 that's enough to kill 333
million Americans nine times over so
Sheriff my question you is your
estimation if describing this describing
to miss kiesling's Point your children
were thinking it was Percocet and ended
up being Fentanyl
what percentage
of what you're seeing from your
experience boots on the ground is coming
from the cartel of this problem or 100
sir 100 is coming from the cartels
um and this is also the fentanyl it
doesn't take much at all they're putting
it in everything they're putting in the
cocaine the heroin the fence the
marijuana they're putting in everything
and I wanted to mention the xylazine I
hope I could take just one second hey
it's a horse tranquilizer right it's a
horse trainer I grew up I grew up in the
horse industry I'm interested in here
what you have to say about this not
approved for human use here's what is
alarming it's a non-opiate opioid which
means that naloxone and Narcan will be
ineffective on it the Phoenix fire
department is starting to see it other
states departments are starting to see
it so the cartels are starting to add
xylazine into the Fentanyl and it will
be impervious to the Narcan of the
naloxone that we often minister to each
other and to other people who are
suffering from a poisoning of Fentanyl
so the cartel's running the gamut
um and so as a colleague said earlier
that you agreed that they're we need to
see them as a terrorist organization
um and in terms of seeing them as a
terrorist organization are they not the
new form of organized crime in America
the new mob that we know and as I was on
the border last week and right across
from the suburbs of El Paso that we're
hearing about operational city-wide
control by the cartel why should we not
be concerned that that is moving into
America like the mob was able to take
hold of control of areas in the United
States Mr reckon we should be concerned
as Americans that violence will spill
over it has spilled over and it will
continue to spill over into America
it'll affect American lives I mean the
fentanyl already is the DEA forgot to
tell you the DEA is now saying that 75
percent of the de are the fentanyl doses
they're finding are lethal doses that's
a staggering number and it's going to
affect a lot of American lives and
quickly Mr chairman to Mr Beer do you
think we have an invasion and Southern
border
there's certainly a problem at our
Southern border yes would you define as
an invasion no not under our
constitution unconstitutionally an
invasion is a military action by a
foreign government
so Mr chairman I'll just say article 4
section 4 guarantees to every state
Republican form of government and
protect those States against an invasion
so the witness was very careful in
knowing that I probably knew the
Constitution the way he answered that
question
and James Madison agrees with that
definition as well he wrote about what
constitutes an invasion under our
constitution as well
thank you gentleman yields uh I now
recognize Mr Garcia from California
thank you Mr chairman and I want to
thank our Witnesses all of them thank
you very much for being here especially
Ms kiesling I'm of course like everyone
in the committee I'm very sorry for uh
for your loss
um I I do want to start uh just my
remarks by just making something just
Crystal Clear
Democrats care about human trafficking
and taking it on we care about a safe
and secure border
we agree that we need to prosecute and
take on drug cartels
and we deeply care about the functional
crisis which we know is is happening
it's a serious issue taking uh taking on
and really causing damage to communities
across the country
but in listening some of our colleagues
here today we it's also pretty apparent
that we also care about something that
many of our Republican colleagues do not
care about and that's an orderly and
Humane immigration system
now I am an immigrant myself I came to
the U.S as a young child and I became a
U.S citizen in my early 20s and I
benefited from the last time our country
actually passed an immigration reform
system which was actually over 35 years
ago and in fact it was Ronald Reagan a
Republican president who signed that
bill that allowed me and my family to
become U.S citizens so I appreciate that
I'm also a small group of members of
Congress that are immigrants and
certainly um on this committee I like to
say that becoming a U.S citizen was the
proudest day of my life
I know firsthand that immigrants like
myself and like my mom who cleaned
houses and worked in clinics cleaning
clinics are patriotic Americans I
consider myself an American Patriot
and I also know that real patriotism
American patriotism is actually about
helping people
we also know that folks that are coming
to our country are seeking help many are
desperate they're coming because in the
tradition of America this is a place
where we afford the American dream that
so many from across this world
and we are a nation of immigrants and so
these broad attacks that we're hearing
today on immigrants today I believe is
un-American immigrants are not all drug
dealers that some would suggest
and we also as immigrants agree that of
course we need to secure our borders and
have an orderly process at our border
and we want to work with our colleagues
to also understand that our ports of
Entry are also places where fentanyl is
clearly coming in in huge numbers
but we also need to have conversations
around drug treatment programs mental
health care and access to care none of
which is happening today at this
committee
and what I don't want to do is conflate
Asylum Seekers with the flow of drugs Mr
Beer I want to thank you for your work
that you've done on this topic and I
would ask you to remind us once again
what the percentage
is of all those of all the folks that
are arrested by border patrol possessing
fentanyl what is actually that
percentage
0.02 not even one percent
correct sir way less than one percent
less than one tenth of a percent and I
think that's an important point because
you wouldn't know that by hearing uh
from so many of my colleagues here
particularly on the other side of the
aisle at this committee and is it also
true
that 91 of drug seizures at checkpoints
are from U.S citizens that's right so
contrary contrary to the myth that is
being I think proposed today by the
chairman and so many others a vast
majority of the fentanyl entering the
U.S is um is actually uh by U.S citizens
at legal ports of Entry is that not true
that's right so and Mr Beer
consistent with your own research
I believe immigrants are also less
likely to commit crimes in this country
isn't that also true that's right
according to the Census Bureau
immigrants both legal and illegal
immigrants are half as likely to end up
behind bars and convicted of crimes in
this country than U.S born residents and
and it's pretty clear that just
listening to some of our colleagues
today you wouldn't know you wouldn't
know any of those facts to be true all
of that is actually true it's documented
I mean I think it's important to
continue to raise those not just in this
committee but across the country so
thank you thank you sir I want to note
that the Biden Administration has also
fought for resources to increase a
secure border as we know this to
modernize our infrastructure Technology
support border agents improve screening
at our legal ports of entry in fact as
we know the infrastructure Bill included
430 million dollars for Customs and
Border Protection
of which most republicans in Congress
voted against and so I think it's
important that at this moment we work
together to deploy these resources and
today I especially find it troubling
that my colleagues are willing to
discuss fentanyl at the border but we
don't have witnesses discussing all
these treatment programs drug addiction
programs or ways to help people that are
suffering or that have men or that need
mental mental health support
this conversation in front of us in this
committee is broken and wrong the
American people are being misled by many
members of this committee and in the
process are demonizing
vulnerable people including immigrants
across this country
I hope we can work together to build a
just and Humane immigration system in
our country when that respects Asylum
Seekers I hope that we can get serious
about addiction and Universal Health
Care but unfortunately those are not the
conversations that we're having here
today I'm hopeful that the next
committee at the next meeting that we
have that we're not using this committee
for political stunts and for
misinformation Mr chairman I yield back
my time
gentlemen yields and uh
the chair recognizes Miss Laura Lee from
Florida
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate you
holding this hearing and I appreciate
each of our Witnesses for being here
with us today to discuss this important
topic
since President Biden took office one
simple fact has become clearer and
clearer every day
border security is National Security
this is an issue that affects each one
of our communities it is an issue that
is endangering our neighborhoods our
families and our children
in my own Community authorities in Polk
County recently confiscated 11 pounds of
Fentanyl following this drug bust our
attorney general announced that
authorities had seized enough fentanyl
in just a few months to kill every
single Floridian our responsibility here
is very serious and I appreciate you all
sharing your insights with us today
Sheriff I'd like to begin with you and
return to the subject of your staff your
resources and the effect this is having
on your operation as a former prosecutor
and judge in Florida I understand the
very broad set of responsibilities that
our local sheriffs have that include
investigating all types of matters
everything from bank robberies to
murders rapes and things that are
happening in the community can you tell
us please how this border crisis is
diverting the resources that you have
and the deputies that you have away from
the other important functions that you
are tasked with serving in your
community absolutely thank you Miss Lee
and I just wanted to comment real quick
that just because they're American
citizens doesn't mean they're not
correlated with the cartels and doing
their work the cartels do that on
purpose so we can sit in here and make
it an immigration issue when it's really
about human trafficking and drug
trafficking into America and those
people that come here are being
victimized we end up paying the price on
the resource level I have to dedicate my
helicopter we had 10 events yesterday
alone where we worked with border patrol
one and 9-1-1 call the other nine of
them were groups of people trying to
come into this country illegally in
camouflage clothes carpet shoes I have
my four canine units dedicated
completely to interdiction catching
drugs and people on the way in and money
and and guns on the way back to Mexico I
have an anti-smuggling unit we have
stone garden units these are all units
that should be dedicated to my community
to continue to protect them however
because the federal government is not
getting the job done on the border and
this is no knock on our troops the
troops the border patrol ice they're
phenomenal they do their job but they've
become babysitters because of the amount
of people coming in and then we end up
picking up the slack and it has a
tremendous impact on our resources and
one thing that I want to be sure we we
share with the public here today as a
prosecutor I worked on cases that
involved human trafficking the
trafficking of women and children uh and
I'd like for you to share with us what
you're seeing in your community around
this horror of human trafficking
absolutely we see every day we can go
out my guys are out working today we'll
probably stop three four five vehicles
piled with people sometimes up to 15 to
20 people in a single vehicle that are
being trafficked by the cartels often
being extorted because they couldn't pay
the full amount at the border or being
put into the sex trade
um so yeah these are the impacts that
we're seeing and we're seeing that
number increase every day exponentially
and it's not okay as Americans to allow
people to be put into the sex trade
whether it's women or children and the
cartel is doing it and they're using
American citizens to do it thank you
Miss kiesling I'd like to now take just
a moment with you as the mother of a
school-aged child I think it's very
important that part of what we do today
is share with parents your story and if
you would uh what would you like to
share with other parents parents of
school-aged children about what happened
to your sons and what you think our
communities and our schools need to know
about this crisis
sorry
starting with the problem with vaping in
middle school I went to the schools and
you know they're putting the drugs in
vaping it's not just
um you know nicotine but they're they
put things like Molly all kinds of
things go into the vaping and these kids
are getting it at a young age that was
their first addiction and I did
everything a parent should do
um there weren't resources at the school
my my friend I mentioned are my former
law Partners husbands the Sheriff Deputy
he's a detective he said when there's
um
identity theft they have a huge packet
for everybody they have stuff on the on
the sheriff's website everything you
need to know how to restore your dunny
there's nothing on fentanyl there's
nothing on Narcan there's nothing that
parents need to know when I asked for
resources we had a share of Deputy in
the school every day and
um and again this is top five school in
the state of Michigan and they they said
well there's a program you can take your
kids to you know the jail and and have
them visit and
that was it I mean there were no
resources I asked them for resources for
information on on for drug addiction
every they had nothing there was nothing
for parents like me and um you know I
tried it's not for lack of trying and my
kids grew up their birth mother was a
drug addict she died six months after
them their uncle died a month after them
he was actually doing
um fentanyl on purpose but my son had
four time I'm sorry five times the
amount of fentanyl in his system that
was enough to kill again this is not an
overdose this is poisoning it's murder
it's homicide please use that language
please don't say overdose
um and
you know you need to have Narcan in your
home and the federal program that the
state had for the the money that they
were getting from the federal government
for Rehab was not real rehab it was just
a flap house we need real rehab
thank you for being here and thank you
for sharing your story Mr chairman I
yield back
gentlelady yields I now recognize Miss
Ramirez from Illinois
thank you chairman
we've heard a lot
of fear-mongering and name-calling today
and I have to say every time our
undocumented Community is referred to as
illegals and criminals
it shows how my Republican colleagues
choose to recognize or not recognize
someone's basic Humanity
and it's a choice
a policy Choice with real consequences
as the only
only member of Congress in a mixed
status family you are saying that my
family
my husband and I should be broken apart
today's hearing is called every state is
a border state
and it's clear that the intention is to
stake fear and Hate
I am proud to represent the people of
Illinois
third congressional district all people
regardless of their status
12 million of our neighbors are still
lacking legal status and they're facing
deportation right now
to be absolutely clear and I want to
make sure it's on the record
we need Humane comprehensive immigration
reform and we need it now
we need to uphold the rights Asylum and
in the meantime we need Protections in
place against deportation and we need
work permits issued for all 12 million
people
Mr buyer there are approximately 600 000
DACA recipients
they pay 6.2 billion dollars in federal
taxes and 3.3 billion dollars in state
and local taxes every single year
DACA recipients like my husband Boris
aren't children anymore
many of them are parents themselves
they're homeowners their teachers their
child care workers they work in our
hospitals
these numbers don't even count the many
undocumented immigrants who are not DACA
recipients who pay payroll taxes who pay
into Social Security but can't claim the
benefits themselves
I strongly support protecting and
expanding Social Security
and at a time when some of my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle would
even consider cutting Social Security
what are the consequences of
deportations on our country's ability to
keep Social Security solvent the Social
Security Administration estimates that
we have a shortfall of about 70 million
people that we will need by 2050 to keep
payments in line with the revenues that
they're receiving so deporting 10
million people would certainly not be in
the interest of maintaining Social
Security payments
obviously people who are in this country
are paying taxes you mentioned the
payroll taxes the vast majority of these
people are working through borrowed
identification or other means by which
they ultimately do pay taxes so it's not
the case that all people who are working
under the table that's that's not how it
happens in most cases thank you so let's
talk about the Border
for those of you that know me know my
story well my mother crossed the border
39 years ago pregnant of me if it
weren't because she crossed the border
escaping poverty nearly dying escaping
rape and all the things that she
experienced uh this woman here wouldn't
be the first Athena in the midwest in
Congress so first I want to say thank
you to all of the people who
courageously risk everything so that
they can escape poverty and save their
lives coming to a place where we call
America that we love so much
many immigrants arriving at the
Southwest border are fleeing dire
situations right now and they're making
that journey through jungles and through
deserts to the Border extremely
vulnerable
recently the administration proposed a
rule limiting migrants eligibility to
apply for Asylum which cbps one app now
let me ask you if they travel through
another country before arriving to the
U.S border and did not seek Asylum first
like a similar measure that was
attempted with the Trump Administration
and the courts didn't allow what would
happen to an asylum Seeker who did not
have access to a smartphone or couldn't
use the CBP one app application
well if they cross the border illegally
because that would be their only other
option then they would be removed the
administration is talking about removing
people to Mexico again possibly removing
people to their home country if they can
in either case what we've seen under
remain in Mexico in title 42 is that
when you ban Asylum and you send people
back to Mexico they re-cross the border
illegally it creates a more dangerous
and less secure border we keep hearing
about these evasions well if people can
request Asylum and enter this country
legally then we do not have this problem
thank you Mr bar I would just end in
saying that we have to stop
criminalizing people and we have to get
to the root cause of the problems that's
what I intend to do as committee I yield
back chairman
gentlelady yields and I now recognize Mr
die Esposito of New York thank you
chairman
first I want to comment that this past
weekend we made a trip with the homeland
security committee this is my second
trip to the Border
and at no point in speaking to local
business owners at no point in speaking
to Educators in no point in speaking to
Farmers or law enforcement
at no point did they ask what party we
were from
so the claims of my colleagues from the
other side that we are politicizing this
is absolutely ridiculous
the fact of the matter is is that we
want to give people the opportunity for
the American dream but we want them to
come through the front door and we want
to do it the right way the Biden border
crisis is more than illegal immigration
criminals weapons illegal narcotics are
coming across the border in alarming
numbers
in fact the vast majority
74 percent of MS-13 members that the
Department of Justice have prosecuted
from 2016 to 2020 were unlawfully
present
sadly Long Island is all too familiar
with the destruction of violent gangs
like MS-13
just last month an MS-13 member pled
guilty for the murder of 18 year old of
an 18 year old in Cal Meadow Park in my
district in March of 21 and the
attempted murder of a Nassau County
Police Department Detective
Sheriff lamb I want to first thank you
for your service
as a former NYPD detective I committed
like you my career to keeping our
streets safe and I know the value of
every single layer and level of law
enforcement
can you talk about the differences
between your relationship now with the
federal government during the current
Biden Administration versus the last
Administration yes sir thank you Mr
despacito and thank you for your service
as well night and day difference night
and day difference we had a great reluct
we always have a great working
relationship with border patrol ice
agents but it stops outside of the State
of Arizona that did as a sheriff I went
to the White House 10 times under the
last Administration not for political
reasons but to address these same issues
we felt like we had a seat at the table
we no longer feel like we have a seat at
that table
thank you
and what ways do you believe our
country's current border policies
incentivize gangs and other criminals to
enter this country
specifically in the cartel and their
involvement you know we can talk
politics all day but when we ask people
why they came here they said because Joe
Biden said we could and this is the
reality of what we deal with every day
so clearly the policies that have been
whether you call them open Borders or
not they are affecting people coming
here and the cartels are taking
advantage and marketing to people in
other countries to come and we and by
default our lack of policies or weak
border security is actually bringing
those people to the doorsteps of the
cartels to be enslaved to be taken
advantage of and like the uh Miss Garcia
mentioned these are good people many of
them but they're being taken advantage
by the cartels that our policy have have
encouraged absolutely thank you thank
you again for your service
as you know New York city mayor Eric
Adams had to beg for federal assistance
for putting arriving aliens in hotels
and building makeshift shelters
throughout the five boroughs at a rate
of 65
116 dollars
per individual
our mayor estimates that New York City
taxpayers will need to spend 2.8 billion
2.8 billion with a B in the next fiscal
year to deal with the rapid influx
doctor according to your testimony as
CEO of the Yuma Regional Medical Center
your hospital has seen a massive influx
of migrants seeking care starting in the
fall of 2021. it's similar to the
Educators that we spoke to across the
border and quite frankly the ones that
I'm talking to across Long Island that
are having budget shortfalls because
they don't budget for the new
individuals coming to the school in the
school year
how many of these migrants have no way
to pay for the care provided in your
facilities and can you speak to the true
cost of Joe Biden's border crisis on the
American economy we've not received any
compensation for any of the migrants
that we've provided care to
um The Border policy has been
significant for us as I said Yuma's got
a population of a hundred thousand
people we've had 300 000 people across
the border and we're the only hospital
they can come to all that care provided
to them is for free it impacts our
organization significantly those are
dollars we would normally put back into
the community put back into resources to
serve additional folks well doctor I
guess you you would probably agree it's
not free we're paying for it it's
definitely not free correct Mr chairman
I yield back
gentleman yields back the chair
recognizes Mr Goldman from New York
thank you Mr chairman
um
Sheriff lamb do you believe that Donald
Trump won the 2020 election
well Joe Biden's the president now no
what do you believe I believe that uh he
lost the election I mean I there's
there's questions about how our election
Integrity I don't know how that relates
to Homeland Security but I have
questions sorry you don't know how
election Integrity relates to Homeland
Security is that your testimony my
testimony is it does relate because
we're seeing how bad it's been under the
last two years so yes it has a
correlation election Integrity what's
that you said you don't believe election
Integrity relates to Homeland Security
is that your testimony I don't know how
this election the question of whether I
think the last president won or lost
it is about this today election
Integrity absolutely matters okay and I
believe that there are a lot of
Americans that have questions about
election integrity and my job is to make
sure that we ensure that we have safe
and secure elections do you believe that
there was fraud in the 2020 election
oh there's always fraud in every
election really there's there's
significant weather however many people
it is there are people that vote for
people that are no longer that are
deceased there are people that vote when
they don't live in a certain resolution
you're right so let me ask you this
question do you think that there was a
fraud that had a material impact on the
results of the 2020 election as a law
enforcement official uh I have seen zero
evidence that would show me the
otherwise right do you believe that
those people who invaded the capital on
January 6th were quote very loving
Christian people
I think that there were a lot of good
people there that were exercising their
First Amendment right and I think they
have in many ways been lumped in with a
group of people that had bad intentions
okay so so you would agree that not
everyone at the Capitol on January 6
would be considered a loving person I
agree that there were people that look
that violated the law and I think those
people are being held accountable okay
because you have been quoted as say
saying that the rioters who were there
on January 6 were very loving Christian
people did you see the videos
that day and January 6th yes sir I've
seen a lot of videos where there were a
lot of good people that were not rioting
and uh you're saying that the rioters
that's different than the people who
were coming and exercising their first
amendment rights so you don't support
every right to exercise our first
amendment you don't support the rioters
who uh beat the police uh and invaded
the capital is that right absolutely not
I am a rule of law guy and if you broke
the law you should be held accountable
so do you support then the 950
prosecutions that the Department of
Justice has brought a rising out of the
events of that day well I know nothing
of those 950 prosecutions I don't I
wasn't there for them I don't know the
the details of those cases so for me to
come and say that I support everyone
would be would be a little bit uh naive
because I don't have the information
sure do you support the uh 10
convictions that the doj has obtained
for seditious conspiracy I am unaware of
the ten convictions nor do I know
anything about those cases really
because they involve the proud boys and
The Oath Keepers are you familiar with
those I am aware of the child boys and
The Oath Keepers have you ever
interacted with them or spent any time
with them I know what you're alluding to
I went to a 2A rally and had some people
come shake my hand who I now somebody
says they're proud boys they had no
indication of that so did you host a
rally for your future Senate run where
there were Oath Keepers and proud boys
there uh no I did not host a rally there
was a 2A rally where I mentioned that I
was strongly considering a senate run
where I have now learned that there were
some proud boys there
would you agree with me that seditious
conspiracy is a conspiracy to overthrow
the government through violence
I'm not sure what the code says exactly
but that sounds pretty familiar okay and
would you agree that the violent
overthrow of our government is a threat
to our national security absolutely okay
um
I just I asked that question because
you've been on record as as questioning
um many things about the 2020 election
many things about the January 6 events
and you just said that election
Integrity uh is is not directly related
to the subject of our hearing today
which is our homeland security
and I'm happy to hear that you agree
with me that the conspiring to overthrow
our government as members of The Proud
boys and Oath Keepers we're convicted of
is a threat to our homeland security and
is a threat to our national security
um last question do you think that the
Mexican drug cartels were created in
no
they they've been around for a long time
haven't they okay okay I yield back
thank you
tired and the chair recognizes Mr Ezell
from Mississippi
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate the
opportunity to discuss how the Biden
administration's failure to secure the
Border affects not just the States along
the southern border but also spreads
through communities in Mississippi and
across our nation
Sheriff lamb first I want to thank you
for your service and your willingness to
testify today
as a former Sheriff I applaud the num
work that your deputies and yourself are
doing and I know the increase in drug
seizures has has been great and a big
burden upon you however as we both know
uh the more illicit drugs that are
caught the more we are missing
based on your experience how have the
drug trafficking networks expanding
expanded their operation since 2020.
they've expanded their operations
tremendously as we heard earlier Tesla
one of the members mentioned they were
making about 500 million dollars a year
they are now making about 13 billion
dollars a year and they're doing it
large in part on taking advantage of
these people that are trying to come
make a better life for themselves
they're paying cash up front which is
only emboldening the cartels and giving
them a lot of money on hand to be able
to buy weapons and and increase their
their footprint along our Southern
border thank you what action should the
federal government take to stop the flow
of illegal drugs into our communities
we should secure our Southern border
that includes continuing building the
wall where it hasn't been built
increasing the amount of border patrol
agents we have increasing technology
turning on the technology that is there
that has been not been turned on for
political reasons these are all things
that need to happen so that we can
continue to get back to securing our
border and and helping these people who
are being trafficked and the drugs from
killing American lives
thank you for that unfortunately
fentanyl poisonings continue to Surge uh
in a single year fentanyl deaths more
than doubled in my home state of
Mississippi and your testimony you call
the I-10 Corridor uh that runs straight
through my district uh and I'd like to
hold up this photo of an I-10 seizure in
Jackson County Mississippi which is over
a thousand miles away from the southern
border here you can see 29 pounds of
mixed heroin and fentanyl which was
found in a single traffic stop clearly
border counties are not the only ones
affected by this crisis
does your department have the resources
it needs to handle the surges and
smuggling and traffic incidents no sir
we do not have the resources we do the
best we can with what we have we're
proud of what we do stop but there's a
lot more that needs to be done
when you come in contact with a human
drug smoke Smuggler how did your
department determine where these
criminals are heading
through a series of questions we have a
lot of guys that are very skilled at
what they do an interdiction
recognizing Mis things that don't line
up in their statements and then we start
to Burke that back and figure out where
it came from a lot of them as you can
imagine don't like to talk to us and
don't like to tell the truth but we do
the best we can to find out where they
came from
one problem that we had in Jackson
County which is still a problem if we
end up taking one of these uh folks that
we've arrested to the hospital do you
have to spend resources and Manpower on
sitting on that person that's in the
hospital Mr ezel that yes in the case
that they committed a crime let's say
they ran from us and we pursued them
there was a crime we would have to sit
on them until we could book them in in a
case where there was no crime committed
we would not have to go sit with them
they would be turned over to border
patrol and border patrol would likely
take that that would take a man off of
his duties on patrol and have to sit in
the hospital yes sir it would well thank
you for your answer the Biden
Administration has allowed the crisis at
the board to persist as we have shown
today every state is a border state and
with that Mr chair I yield back
gentleman Niels the chair now recognizes
Miss Clark from New York
thank you Mr chairman and I thank our
ranking member I think our Witnesses for
their testimony here today
the mission of the Homeland Enterprise
is vast and complex
it's important for the success of the
Homeland mission that we focus on the
challenges
of law enforcement in the midst of an
urgent migrant crisis
and
the conflation of the opioid and
Fentanyl crisis with Asylum seeking is
quite unfortunate
it distracts from the real work of
surging resources and Personnel required
to win against drug courtels and drug
dealers
as the daughter of immigrants I find it
extremely distasteful
to sit here and look at how we've used
the plight of our fellow Americans
to exploit
exploit uh what is uh clearly xenophobia
Miss kisling I am deeply sorry for your
loss
but I know that with the proper
resources dedicated to drug programs
drug rehabilitation education
some of the things that you mentioned to
some of my colleagues that you did not
have access to in your child's High
School
we could save many more lives and I hope
that you'll become a more vocal advocate
for delivering those resources to your
community because I'll Stand shoulder to
shoulder with you and making those
resources available
and um
Dr trensel you you have a hospital
that could do great work in that space I
hope you too will become an advocate for
the type of treatment that our nation
needs to get past what has been a
decades-long addiction crisis
our decades-long broken immigration
system needs reform
I'm hopeful
that when we clear or when we clear the
air of the smoke that has been the smoke
screen that's been erected by those who
would use our crisis of addiction
to demonize those migrants who have
risked life in limb seeking safety and
freedom
in one of the greatest nations in the
world
that we will get down to the business of
a 21st century immigration system in the
United States of America
Mr Beer you mentioned that immigrants
to be key contributors to our economy
and having a restrictive immigration
system only leads to millions of people
who want to contribute their skills and
hard work to do so illegally which leads
to violations of the law
can we ensure that immigrants who are
big contributors to the American economy
can have lawful Pathways while they are
awaiting legal status without the fear
of being ripped away overnight and sent
back to the dangerous conditions from
which they've escaped we have to start
by looking at what's causing people to
come to the border of course when you
look at Cuba and Venezuela these are
socialist governments that have
destroyed their economies and trapped
people in poverty for for many years now
Nicaragua is going in an authoritarian
way uh we've seen what's happening in
Central America with the violence and
crime there Mexico we hear all the
testimony about the cartels and the
violence that is occurring people are
coming because they're being driven out
not because they really want to to leave
their homes and so we need processes and
procedures that allow them to apply to
come legally and that will free up
resources for law enforcement to come
we've already seen successful programs
to do this whether it be the Ukrainian
program we talked about earlier or the
programs for Venezuela and these other
countries that were just rolled out in
January saw a massive drop in people
arriving that's because people know if
they can apply legally if there's a
viable shot they will go know the legal
route because of all of the risks coming
illegally to this country thank you very
much and not to mention Haiti of course
right I'm sorry for but that Mr chairman
I yield back uh thank you at this time I
recognize the uh gentleman uh from the
great state of Alabama Mr strong
thank you Mr chairman
um to the witnesses I think each of you
for joining us here today uh as my
colleagues mentioned last weekend
several of us were able to make a trip
to the southern border and witness
firsthand this administration's border
crisis this trip confirmed what we
already knew to be true our Southern
border is in crisis it's hard to imagine
anyone could reach a different
conclusion the impacts are felt all
around the country my district
specifically has seen a drastic rise in
the number of fentanyl related deaths
we're also seeing more drugs on the
streets which many local Law Enforcement
Officers attribute to the Mexican
cartels and this administration's
immigration policies I've spent almost
four decades As A Firefighter emergency
medical technician and have personally
worked over 100 overdoses I believe it's
no coincidence that the last two years
have seen a drastic uptick in these
calls I have several photos here to
share with you today
each of these are from drug bust in
Madison County Alabama within the last
six months
I'm proud of the tireless work of the
law enforcement officials to get these
drugs off the streets of our community
these three pictures alone amount to
enough fentanyl to kill the entire
population of Alabama
this is uh from only two seizures in
Madison County Each of which originated
in Mexico
you will notice that in these pictures
stacked team badge number 12.
that right there is Officer Billy
clardy's badge
he went to sportman high school we grew
we went to school together he was killed
in Huntsville Alabama on December the
6th 2019 working to protect North
Alabama from these drugs and was killed
by a drug dealer
this issue is not a republican issue it
is not a democratic issue it's an
American issue
north south east west Rich poor black
white Latino Indian drugs do not
discriminate every family has been
affected one way or the other fentanyl
heroin cocaine human smuggling is
rampant at the southern border no
American is safe
Miss kissling I'm sorry for the
circumstances that have brought you to
this United States uh to this hearing
no parent should have to experience what
you have as a father my heart goes out
to you
you have uh you may have seen reports
that a Providence in Canada will uh
decriminalize possession of several
drugs including heroin morphine fentanyl
cocaine methamphetamine
an MDMA
do you think this is the right approach
to take
in Oregon they've been legalizing or
decriminalizing a bunch of different
drugs fentanyl is not something that you
could just control like that fentanyl is
used for anesthesia and surgeries you
know you have to have an
anesthesiologist present to make sure
someone doesn't die okay where are we
going to have a country full of
anesthesiologists provided for all of
them um I heard him say oh they you know
let's make fentanyl strips available you
know so many of the children that are
dying are are young they have no
knowledge of anything like this you
think the drug dealers get they're
they're trying to kill off our children
the reason why they're adding this new
drug in
um the sedative from for you know
tranquilizer for horses is because they
don't want them to be saved by Narcan
they're trying to kill off our
population this is a war thank you you
mentioned that drugs were indeed from
Mexico does it make you feel better to
hear this Administration says there's no
crisis at the southern border
eat ignorance he's that's absolute Clues
to say something like that
thank you uh Sheriff lamb thank you for
being before so I've had an opportunity
to meet you once before in your
testimony you highlighted the importance
of local law enforcement and dealing
with the crisis at the border over the
last several years uh some of my
colleagues across the aisle have called
to defund law enforcement and police
what would that mean for local efforts
at the border if law enforcement
agencies did not receive if they were to
start cutting funding that's a great
question sir and if you cut out the
local funding it would be even worse of
a problem a lot of the stops you're
seeing a lot of the help the the bus the
drug busts are happening on a local
level because it's getting through the
borders so even though would they say 90
percent is happening at the checkpoints
in Arizona it's 52 and 48 percent so the
majority of ours is a half of it is
still coming through between the
checkpoints thank you Dr trenchel uh as
you are well aware we have an opal
opioid crisis in the United States
particularly with fentanyl's rise in
popular popularity prior to the Border
crisis how often would you say that you
have treated patients for fentanyl
poisoning it's definitely gone up since
the the borders were opened I don't have
those specific numbers but it's
definitely an increase thank you within
the last two years have you experienced
an increase in treating patients with
fentanyl poisoning yes we have
could you please describe what the
treatment for fentanyl poisoning entails
expired uh thank you Mr chairman
I now recognize uh Miss Titus from
Nevada
certainly everybody agrees with that and
also other illegal drugs brought by
criminals brought by drug dealers
brought by cartels uh this is a crisis
at the border but I don't want to go
back to something Mr swalwell brought up
a little bit just for emphasis I'd like
to remind this uh hearing and these
folks who are here that when this came
up for us to consider putting more
resources into fighting this drug
carrying over the southern border there
are all but two two Republicans who are
currently serving in this Congress voted
against the Appropriations Bill all but
two voted against it now that
Appropriations Bill had critical
Provisions to help DHS manage the Border
it included 400 million dollars for
inspection systems to protect drugs I'd
like to hear from those people who think
this is such a big problem why they
didn't vote for the resources to go
after it so we wouldn't have tragedies
like the deaths from fentanyl we
wouldn't have the cartels coming over
here we wouldn't have the crisis at the
border we would be doing something about
it but no only two Republicans voted for
those resources in the Appropriations
Bill to deal with these questions these
problems these crises that you all have
mentioned and harped on throughout this
hearing I'd like to change the subject
just a little bit to talk about the
Immigrant communities in in this country
I live in Las Vegas it's an
international City people from all over
the world come there and people from all
over the world live there we have
growing populations from Asia as well as
from Latin America they work back at a
house front of the house gardening they
are contributing members to the
community and I have a lot of mixed
status families you will have one person
who is a citizen one person who is a
dreamer one person on TPS and one person
who may not even know what their status
is but they are all contributing to the
economy Mr bear would you talk a little
bit about some of the ways positive ways
that immigrants who come here do make
contributions to our economy to our
culture to our society Society in
general of course there's two I
mentioned 250 billion dollars in state
and local tax revenues that are paid by
these people they work at higher rates
they are employed in occupations that
actually create jobs for other U.S
workers so if you look at a restaurant
you'll see the immigrants a lot of times
they'll be working in the back of the
restaurant creating jobs for for
Americans in the front of the restaurant
the same thing goes on across the entire
economy these people are contributors
they're expanding the economy economy by
trillions of dollars every year that's
helping bring down the cost of goods and
services because the more our economy
grows the more uh items are available on
the shelves of of every store in America
and that's a benefit directly to
Americans I just met with the national
French
and the Latin chamber
and a lot of people become more
prosperous and contribute to the
community because they fund the Little
League teams and things like that most
of the franchises in Las Vegas have been
opened in the last several years by
immigrants
women immigrant women are going into
small businesses and building those
numbers and and we know that immigrants
are twice as likely to be entrepreneurs
than U.S born residents it's part of
their culture right if you're willing to
get up and be entrepreneurial enough to
come and change what country you're
living in you are willing to take
another risk to start a business and
contribute in that way which also
benefits uh uh consumers by having
another option available to them good
you mentioned briefly because you said
it before but about the guest worker
programs that should go all year that
might be helpful to areas dependent on
tourism like Las Vegas oh absolutely so
we have two seasonal guest worker
programs for non-agricultural and
agricultural but you cannot get a guest
worker visa for Industries like Dairy
and livestock that are year round and
have a need throughout the season of
course also in Las Vegas you're you're
dealing with tourism again they're
ineligible for these visas because of
the fact that you have to show it's a
seasonal a seasonal nature a temporary
job and so that restriction is
ultimately creating this process why
people come over to fill those jobs
they're coming in illegally because
they're not a legal option available to
them it's no longer just a season in Las
Vegas it's a year round
yes absolutely and and it's you know the
growth of of tourism industry and in
many places desperate for workers and
you're seeing I've seen it I'm sure
every member of this committee has seen
it the decline in service as a result of
the the worker shortage throughout the
country thank thank you very much I
yield back
a gentle lady yields
without a objection the gentleman from
Arizona Mr ciscomani is permitted to sit
on this panel and ask questions of the
witnesses
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you to my fellow members of the
committee for allowing me to wave onto
this committee as a guest to have the
opportunity to discuss such an important
issue to my community I want to thank
the panel as well for taking the time to
be here to be here with us a little
background I was born in Mexico I'm an
immigrant myself
first time I was in Capitol Hill was in
2003 as an intern and I still had a
green card at that time as an adult I'm
back now 20 years later as a member of
Congress only in America can we have
these kind of opportunities this is the
land of opportunity and like Mr Garcia
and Mrs Ramirez we enjoy the
opportunities this country offered us
and our appearance and that's why I'm so
proud to be here so proud to be an
American and so proud to be an immigrant
as well serving in Congress today I
really believe that we can have a
conversation about immigration and about
border security I care about both I've
lived both obviously being an immigrant
and also living in the Border community
and then and today I think it's
important to focus the issue of what
we're talking about in my in my case and
my question for the sheriff thank you
for being here Sheriff lamb and I
appreciate your time and making the trip
up here it's always good to see you at
home but always nice to see you here as
well it's around the area of of that
we've been discussing in uh around
Fentanyl and in Arizona fentanyl
trafficking has taken its toll on our
communities more than 8 600 pounds of
fentanyl have been seized along the
South West Border in our first four
months in this fiscal year this is
enough to kill more than 1.9 million
people
could you speak on the impact that this
has on our young children
um and uh and those who are true victims
and I want to take the chance real quick
to a ma'am offer you my deepest
condolences I'm a dad of six three boys
and three girls I can't imagine the the
pain that you've gone through and I and
I thank you for your bravery and being
here I've actually spoken to two
different mothers this last week uh of
of that have lost uh their their
children to this tragic crisis
um Sheriff would you mind speaking on
the fentanyl issue please yes sir thank
you it's always great seeing you too Mr
systemati uh yeah the fentanyl is be is
the leading cause of death not just
amongst Americans between the ages of 18
and 45. it is the leading cause of death
amongst children in Arizona 44 children
in 2021 died from fentanyl poisonings
seven were under the age of one two were
under the age of five those are some
staggering statistics in my County we've
had uh seven we're at 73 in 2021 people
that were poisoned not just children and
now that is the number is currently
sitting at 61 until we get all the
numbers back in from the medical
examiner we will exceed that 73 as well
so it's a big problem for our children
here's the key point and it's been
mentioned earlier
it is a 100 percent preventable
in our gel I do a ton of re-entry
programs I help people with mental
health addiction drug addiction we work
tirelessly because and inevitably the
sheriff's office we are your de facto
mental health institutes and we have to
deal with more addiction issues than
most people do and so we work hard to
try to stop it but it is affecting our
children thank you sheriff and I'll take
one more question I want to be
respectful of the time uh right on the
on the I-10 that goes through your
entire County I call that and many
others to the artery of our estate for
trade for Commerce for transportation
between the two major cities in the
state also for trafficking and one of
the things that we've been seeing is an
increase in high speed chases in this
area many that are starting in Cochise
County and then go through Pima County
and also Pinal County where lives are
being lost not only of
bystanders and innocent drivers but also
of those being trafficked in these uh
Infamous rollovers that we're seeing an
increase on would you mind touching on
that as well well please absolutely one
of the statistics we had is 461 percent
increase in the last two years for
Pursuits involving human trafficking a
lot of times these are kids driving so
they run and they have 10 people in
their car a lot of times they'll lose
control of the vehicle causing the the
injury and death to not just themselves
sometimes or innocent citizens but also
to those people that are just trying to
come here to make a better life they
become the victims of this as well thank
you Sheriff again thank you to the panel
and thank you to my colleagues and Mr
chair I yield back gentlemen yields back
and the chair recognizes Mr Garbarino
from New York thank you Mr chairman and
thank you thank you member for having
this hearing and all of our Witnesses
have been here for quite a long time
today we really appreciate it but this
just shows I think I've been here this
is my third year uh here and this is
probably one of the best attended
hearings from Members with all the
questions so I think you can all
understand how important this issue is
I'm from New York as you heard along
Island
and as we've heard today that uh
fentanyl does not discriminate no family
no community no region is safe from the
the threats presented by trafficking a
fennel across the border in 2021 Suffolk
County where I'm from Lost 425 residents
to overdoses from opioid pain relievers
including Fentanyl New York State health
commissioner reported last year that
three quarters of all overdose deaths in
New York
State now involve fentanyl uh Sheriff
Lam you mentioned in your testimony the
number of fentanyl pills seized by your
deputies increased by 610 percent since
2020 I know you just uh my colleague you
just answered a couple of questions
about what your deputies are doing
can you get a little more involved into
what some of the some of some of the
Technologies your team has found useful
in detecting these pills that the
cartels are bringing over
absolutely thank you sir there is a lot
of Technology you can use that will test
the density of the vehicle to be able to
see if they're packing it inside the
vehicles but a lot of this stuff is very
rudimental we had a vehicle that we
stopped that had three trays of food in
it our deputies were searching the car
moved one of the trays it was heavier
than it probably should have been they
stuck a stick inside the tray it only
went down about this deep in a tray this
deep so then they scraped the food back
only to find three trays had 227 000
fentanyl pills in those trays of food we
also stopped a car that had a driver the
the per the passenger in the front seat
was dressed as a nun she had a veil over
her face she had a Bible on her lap our
investigation ended up real revealing
that she had eight pounds of granular
fentanyl which would kill millions of
people underneath her dress in that
traffic stop they will use every tactic
they can so what do you need from us
what kind of tools can we send you well
I'm a big states rights guy I would love
for the government to back off and let
the states do our deal
but I mean if we could send you some
technology or some you know some actual
you know uh what what technology could
we do not not rules not you know you
know mandates but what could we give you
what could Congress send you and that
would help you do your job and sir I
appreciate you asking that I would love
we could use drones we could use some of
these uh those those uh I'm not sure the
thermometer thermal uh the thermal
machines that actually read the thermal
of the vehicle
um honestly we could just use more
funding for uh resources getting our
guys out on the streets a lot of this
has stopped just like I mentioned
earlier with good old-fashioned police
work and the guy's not willing to give
up I appreciate that I'm I'm not sure if
they're clocked oh you started but uh
I guess I think it started yeah I think
your time is up I'll yield back thank
you all right uh the gentleman yields
and I think the ranking member wanted to
add something to the record so I now
recognize Mr Thompson for the purpose of
placing something into the record thank
you very much Mr chairman I actually
Anonymous consent to submit statements
from the first Focus campaign for
Children Human Rights first and
Coalition for human immigrant rights
so ordered
thank you Mr chairman or Mr ranking
member
um
I want to thank the witnesses uh for
being here this concludes our first
full Hearing in this Congress I want to
thank the members for
their time and
uh their Congeniality through most of
this we have differences of opinion very
clearly but I think everyone wants
what's best for our country
to our Witnesses Miss keisling thank you
for sharing your heart and the tragedy
that occurred to you Sheriff the
challenges you're facing I appreciate
your time today Dr trench really
appreciate you we we've spent probably
more of the time and appropriately so on
the human costs but as we go forward
throughout this Congress there'll be
more opportunities to delve into the
financial costs of what's going on as
well Mr Beer I appreciate you and I
appreciate your passion thanks for being
here
um
you know we've heard a lot today that
the the crisis is due to a lack of
resources I just before I close I want
to make the point that
you know the budget didn't decrease in
January 21.
the the number of people on the border
didn't decrease
on January 21.
but a massive surge of people came
across our border then
what changed Was the removal of some
significant policies that had been shown
to work
and uh I think it's very important to
stress that
I think resources are needed and I agree
with the comments from both sides of the
aisle on that issue but I want to stress
the massive wave of 4.7 million 1.2
million gotaways more than the past two
administrations combined
didn't happen because we cut the budget
or we cut the people
it happened because the president cut
the policies
um and with that we will stand adjourned
what we're going to do just uh let me
before I adjourn us we're going to take
a 15-minute break we have to reset for
the votes on the oversight plan it looks
like votes on the floor are are delaying
a little bit
so we'll be able to knock that out so
for this hearing today again thank our
Witnesses thank our members We Stand
adjourned
good job